what's up believe nation welcome to
season two of million dollar businesses
where i break down what it takes to
build a million dollar plus business in
different industries
this season we look at the restaurant
industry i sit down with nelson braff
the founder of the hunt and fish club
here in manhattan new york city and he's
going to tell me what it takes to be a
success in the restaurant business the
hunt and fish club is a three-time star
diamond award winner has clients like
bill gates laurie grineer derek jeter
justin timberlake and investors like
gary vee nelson's waiting for me inside
let's go in and pick his brain 90 of
restaurants in new york never see an
anniversary wow
some percentage of them never open their
doors wow and it's uh
if i'm off i'm off slightly it's a
horrific number there's no such thing as
information overload you need
information in this business frankly i
wish i would have known when i started
everything i know now
nelson thank you for joining me today
thank you for making the time in your
beautiful restaurant it's an honor to be
here thank you
or just quick contact from our audience
who may not be familiar with the hunting
fish club give us the quick story of
your success um so a number of years ago
we're about to celebrate our fourth
anniversary this january this coming
january
my partner raytown sugarman and i were
went out to a steakhouse in new york
city and it was during the summer it was
warm
and sitting not too far from us was a
guy in eyes out shirt jeans and open
sandals and we looked at each other and
said when
did it become okay in a new york city
steakhouse to be that
casual and
it just seemed a little odd to us we're
both old souls and we remember the day
people wore jackets and so on and like
when when did this go away so we came up
with an idea of
let's
do our own steak and seafood house
and
while we don't have a dress code
necessarily we wanted to design a place
where people might feel a little
uncomfortable not being dressed a little
bit better we wanted to bring back some
elegance and some of like an old world
look and feel to new york city place
we used as role models
if that's the right word if frank
sinatra sammy davis and dean martin were
alive today what would the restaurant
they aiden actually look like
so we spoke to some friends of theirs
who are thankfully still with us and
mutual friends and they told us the
design elements of what they liked so
we created that and like i said while we
don't have a dress code we wanted a
little bit of the
formality of
of that era gone by
and frankly i think we nailed it so it's
been a straight ride since then i'm
kidding it's anything but a straight
ride um and uh but we're doing okay cool
so in this series we are gonna break
down your ten lessons on how to build a
successful restaurant for somebody who
wants to get into the industry after i'm
done doing it i might actually watch it
so i learned there you go okay watch it
back
uh so lesson number one was the
importance of passion so talk to me
about passion why is it so important
you i mean you come from being a lawyer
how does how does your passion for the
restaurant business get started
talking through that that's a great
question frequently asked by my wife
actually okay because she started out
marrying a lawyer she ended up with a
guy who owns a restaurant or a couple of
restaurants
and passion it's not just restaurants
it's anything you do
everyone has to work to support
themselves but it's not really work if
you love it you do better at it you
don't feel like you're working you look
forward to going in every day
um and i still do other things i'm not
just in the restaurant business but i
love this like it's not necessarily my
income it is my passion
i i love being here i love seeing the
people i love feeling like i'm throwing
a party every night and while we
certainly charge people to come to my
party i want them to enjoy
as if they were in my house at a party
right and i i love every part of it and
frankly if you don't
you can't work and not in this business
anyway it's too tough if you don't love
it it's not gonna work
i mean restaurant business one of the
highest failure rates
of any business
and and it's actually a misnomer to call
it a business i seem to remember the
business there's some correlation
between risk and reward okay here it's
there is none there is no relationship
at all between risk it's all risk and
very little reward
so it's kind of a hobby that pays or
loses maybe but uh to call it a business
is almost a challenge okay
interesting
and then you've got
so many people who want to start a
restaurant there's so many people who
love food and love the idea of having
their own place and especially a
beautiful place like this here in the
middle of manhattan everyone who serves
uh has a dinner party at home and the
guests tell them wow you're terrific
cook right thinks they could run a
restaurant right my wife is a terrific
cook okay she couldn't run this place so
so what would you tell
those people if somebody's thinking
about starting the restaurant tell them
the best job in a restaurant is customer
okay
and they should try to stick that no
it's um there's a lot of components to
go into it and they should learn before
they
spend okay don't just jump into it it
won't work so how what what's your
advice i mean how it helps you to go
learn
go work in a restaurant group learn how
to open what to look for site location
funding like there's a lot of components
to it
it's not as simple as build it and they
will come and serve good food and
everyone will show up and there'll be a
line around the block it doesn't work
like that at all
the
i would tell them just be careful bring
in people learn it and bring in people
who have done it
otherwise here
i don't remember the exact statistic but
somewhere in the neighborhood of ninety
percent of restaurants in new york never
see an anniversary wow
some percentage of them never open their
doors wow and it's uh
if i'm off i'm off slightly it's a
horrific number right it's it's not good
and
so how do you increase your likelihood
of success it will get to that
throughout the day but um
you there's no such thing as information
overload you need information in this
business frankly i wish i would have
known when i started everything i know
now
i i've made a lot of the mistakes that i
will
suggest people try to avoid okay
if we had to pick one what would be a
big one money
okay under capitalized okay we're gonna
get the funding that's coming up that's
coming up
that's a big one okay and how
did you always have a passion for the
restaurant business no okay never
thought about it in my life okay
uh couldn't have been further from my
thought process okay um i went to law
school my parents were civil servants my
uncle was a lawyer and i figured i saw
we needed about six months late time to
plan a vacation he sort of went on a
whim okay i like the wimp thing so i'm
gonna be a lawyer okay i became a lawyer
it was fun i did it for a lot of years i
i liked the people more than i liked the
work right so then i went into finance i
did that
somewhere along the line i started to
get into the mindset of
not in the hospitality business but i
was out late at night in clubs and going
to restaurants we
my partner and i had these friends who
were late night people and i used to go
and i felt like a fish out of water but
i was found myself in nightclubs at two
in the morning on monday nights i'm like
if i'm gonna do this i need to own it
because it's certainly not good for my
career right um
and so we
built a nightclub which did well
um but i didn't like the model you build
it and you're planning to go out of
business the day after you've been like
how long is this going to last
and then we sort of switch to
restaurants
so we're still still in the nightlife
genre
but they're staying power right there's
no such thing as a hundred-year-old
nightclub right right there's
a bunch of hundred-year-old restaurants
is that the goal for you
pass it down i was i don't know uh maybe
pass it down sell it i'm not into the
pass it down thing because then you're
sort of telling your kids what they
should be doing with their life and i'm
not a big fan of that i'm more into the
world is a big place
take wherever it takes you let it take
you um do you like the idea of having
this place last for 100 years or trying
to get through the lease right
now if it does
if it does it's fine um
like some
people have used the expression you
build these with an idea to sell like no
you build it to make money
and
everything that goes into that
which includes customer experience
because if they have a bad experience
you can't make money
and if you
are successful then somebody will want
to buy it is that the goal
i'm not that far out my goal is to do
well yeah my goal is to maybe get more
of them perhaps if that's where the
world takes us and if down the road
somebody wants an order it's fine if it
doesn't happen that's also fine
it's
it's just that's not part of my universe
of thought my universe of thought is
it has to be successful financially and
i want people to
enjoy coming here and those two go side
by side if i'm good at the second part
the first part takes care of itself
right
so so help me make this connection
because we've got
you know this lesson is about the
importance of passion you have to love
it this is not can't just be a hobby for
you it's it's a brutal business of all
the ones that start like this is not the
one to start
but then hearing your story your guy who
came from
the law and didn't really have a passion
for restaurants so so i'm worried about
somebody watching this and then saying
well i i could do that like i'm a banker
or something i should just go start a
restaurant because there's still some
like element of
deep passion for you to do this the
passion at least for me came after i was
in it okay i didn't know that i had a
passion for it
i was i got economically
motivated early on i never had my
thoughts that i would be running this
place and making day-to-day decisions
and
getting three o'clock am calls about a
plumbing leak and that wasn't in my
wheelhouse right it just sort of
happened partly to protect the
investment side of it and partly because
i just found myself loving it and i'd
say i don't know if i loved it because i
was good at it or if i was good at it
because i loved it i'm not sure
but either way i found myself being here
talking to guests and having fun and
the guests came to see me and i liked
seeing them and i liked that a lot would
you recommend that path for other people
i would recommend a path of
if you think
you're going to be the key person
because you might i was never planned on
being the front person or the main
face of a restaurant um
if somebody is prepared for that then
yeah that if that's what they're going
into it for
um
and which is why i said they should dip
their toe in and maybe get a job in it
or something like that before actually
committing because once you're committed
there's no halfway in this business
halfway is you won't last a year like
either you're all in or don't get in
right it's different if somebody invests
money it's if it's economically in their
wheelhouse that's fine
it's not a commitment of passion or
whatever
and that's a different thing but if they
want to be the one who
literally
picks out the tablecloths and says hello
to the guests at the door and
and deals with the stress of oh my god
it's snowing this week we're going to
lose three days of revenues how am i
going to pay the rent right if you want
to be that person then yeah you better
love it because you're going to have the
negatives that's unavoidable
the kitchen will
the
dishwasher will break on your busiest
night invariably and
um it'll snow when you have your
christmas party planned that everything
that can go wrong is gonna happen so
you're gonna have to deal with all the
negatives yeah you if you don't love the
business you won't have enough of the
positives and so if somebody wants to
get into the business they're going to
go dip their toe
what what's the role what what's the
best role for me in my server am i
trying to become gm before like at what
point do i yeah i would do management
okay in it um and the other part is
understand your personality um are you
outgoing are you introverted and be
honest
with yourself so
um an outgoing an outgoing person
personality on a full-service restaurant
is a big deal like it's a people
business i i don't know about you but my
wife and i we love going to restaurants
where we know the people there and maybe
they have the best food and maybe it's
average it certainly can't be terrible
you wouldn't go there right but people
like going where they feel like they
know it's not just going out to dinner
it's going out to see your friends or
your friends happen to work at a
restaurant
um so
that's part of what i wanted to create
here like i speak to people during the
day and i'm like i'm working tonight one
day come in and they do
um and i like seeing them and i hope
they like seeing me i guess they do
because they come they come back i
suppose um
and
and if you're very introverted it
doesn't mean you can't go into the
business you just know that you probably
aren't going to be that
person unless you force yourself into it
and you can't force yourself into it i
growing up i was very introverted i
never knew i had the wherewithal to walk
around the restaurant dining room and
say hi to people i didn't know
peter told me that when i was 10 years
old then i looked at you like i had
three heads but
i like it and because i like it i think
i've become good at it um
and i
truly have fun when there's no crisis
happening on the floor
i really do love meeting people i met a
couple from iowa the other night
uh it was great they were in they've
never been to new york they came in for
the holiday season it was great so
they'll actually be back later tonight
they had such a good time and i told
them how to
insult the waiter and they'll get a free
dessert out of it
and they did and then they found out
that i had actually instructed them and
we had fun with it and so they came to a
town they i don't know where an eye or
where they're from but i'm willing to
bet it's not a place as big as new york
right um
and all of a sudden they're at a
restaurant and they feel important and
they're having fun and laughing with the
owner of a restaurant that read about or
heard about and it was a pretty cool
experience and they're coming back two
nights later three nights later so yeah
i love that kind of stuff and then i see
people who i know for
a couple years now and i see people i've
known my whole life like a lot of the
people i'm friendly with in the
restaurant i met through the restaurant
and i see them all the time now and they
really are friends so
i love it
so that's the good part if you don't
have that
recognize it and have somebody who does
as a partner as a partner as a well-paid
employee right someone who's there
they call it hospitality for a reason
if it if it was only about the food you
could have a takeout place right right
like you don't need to
do all of this
it's part of a total experience
uh that from the time they walk in till
the time they walk out and you want
everyone to feel like they had a really
good time not just that the food was
really good the food should be really
good i would never minimize that that's
and we spend endless hours trying to
assure that
but it it's more than that experience
like if you go to a broadway show and an
actor is really good but the play stinks
you're not gonna have that good time to
say wow he's a great actor but i don't
have that good time because i play stuff
right if the food is really good
that's great but it's only a it's an
important part of the puzzle but it's
not the total puzzle
got it today we're talking about the
importance of culture
so nelson what do you have for us why is
culture so important
at least in the restaurant business
perhaps in any business you kind of have
to know who and what you are
starting with
what are you how do you envision
yourself what are you going to look like
what are people going to feel when they
walk in um
what do you want them to take out of it
your customers
the idea that you have no identity you
don't know what your customer looks like
you don't know whether you're where
they're coming from who they are
what their demographic is
the
that wouldn't work so
any culture can work but i define
culture as knowing who and what you are
and who and what your audience expects
you to be
we had a very specific target when we
built hunt and fish club and i would
think any restaurant
should at least of this type and i guess
if you're a hot dog stand on the side of
a road your demographic is anybody
driving it on a long ride and
is hungry right right
um so but here that's it's not the case
whether you're a
a pizza salon or a diner or an upscale
steak and seafood house you kind of have
to know who you are what you are what
image you want to portray and sort of be
loyal to that
build it and they will come is a movie
it's not reality right right build it
and stare at it
is the reality if you don't know who
your audience is and how to get them
and so that's when you define culture
that's
it's part of the total experience and
what you want that experience to be so
so what would you define that as for for
here so hutton fish club what is the
culture that you have created for your
guests
we want
this to have felt like as i mentioned in
the prior lesson a little bit of a
throwback a little bit of an upscale
that once upon a time new york felt like
this
um
we want this to be a
nicer night out for people such as an
anniversary or a birthday not the place
where you go to hang out every
you know every day for lunch and that's
fine if it did but if you do it because
you want that upscale sort of experience
um
that's the easy part the hard part of
saying we want it to be an upscale
experience
is to not feel uncomfortable or rigid
so that was the challenge the upscale
and comfortable simultaneously like the
name hunt and fish club when people
asked us about club they thought we were
saying like it was a membership club and
that wasn't what it was about the word
club was used in the context of
clubhouse
we want people to
come here and feel like that they're
likely to already see somebody they know
and to come and hang out even if they're
alone just show up at the bar chances
are you'll know people so we wanted more
of a clubhouse feel
than exclusive club that was absolutely
not the intent and in the beginning
there was some confused messaging in
that and not anymore but right at the
beginning there was
and we particularly targeted in our case
um
the post
911 finance crowd moving into midtown
manhattan post 9 11 a lot of the wall
street community moved into midtown and
there were restaurants
in lower manhattan
that were traditionally sort of hang out
places for that community
um and we try to say what's the midtown
version of that and there were
restaurants the community went to so
that there's a difference between a
place you go to and a go-to restaurant
so the places in midtown where they went
to because of convenience it was on
their block was around the corner or
whatever but there were no restaurants
that were
people knew as this is the place where
our industry goes whether it's finance
or hedge funds media those kind of
things so
we're saying like what can we build to
get
targeting that community that was our
demographic
much different than a barbecue
restaurant i'm involved with
100 different but the concept is the
same of who's your audience
how do you
reach them how do you appeal to them and
how do you make them want to come back
the underlying model
is the same
who the people are may be different and
sometimes they're the same during the
week it's one and on the weekends it's
the other
but the culture is
more identifying and targeting your
audience and if you're successful
you pull from places that just want to
share that experience even if it's not
your target audience
so
we got very lucky in that the look and
feel created that
through personal relationships and other
things we were able to initially because
it sounds good in theory right we want
this to be the go-to place for
finance or media people that sounds
great right how do you make it happen
exactly right and it's
i remembered a a partner of mine uh
certainly mr scaramucci you might know
the name yeah um
when i asked him that because he's
brilliant in his own way
and he said gray's papaya
i don't know if you know grace papaya
it's a very famous hot dog place in
manhattan been there forever
and everyone says they have the best hot
dogs in new york amigos how did that
happen i don't know because they put a
sign on their wall 40 years ago best hot
dogs in new york the sign's still up
okay so
he said the way we're going to become
that is we're going to tell everybody
that we are and they'll believe us
and we did and they did and that's what
we become
i don't know that that's a lesson that
always works but that's really how we
did it we just started telling people
before we signed our lease
there was some media um
telling us telling the world that we
were building this place for this
community and
it was already being discussed right
does that then also
help influence even you walking in your
team walking in hiring you know your
your chef and and your members like this
is this is what we're creating right
it's it's both this is what they expect
we have to deliver it right right so
we're saying this is what we're going to
be this is the audience we want and once
we get the audience we want
we have to give what they expected so
each feeds the other
and
again that ties into culture i've had
many staff meetings about we get a
handful of
recognizable faces and names that come
through here so everybody knows them the
staff the host everybody knows
but that we teach them like hey if
you're coming into this restaurant
everybody is sort of a somebody
and
you don't know who you're serving but
even more importantly than
who they may be they're coming here
expecting a certain
experience right whether it's somebody
who does this every day and they work
around the corner for one of the
networks or if it's somebody who saves
up for an entire year
to go out with their spouse for their
anniversary dinner and it's a really big
deal to them
and a lot of ways i care more about them
because like they have choices and they
only get to do it once and
you don't want to mess it up for them
and
so culturally you have to treat every
person as a vip and
because that's what they expect and they
go home feeling like they got what they
were hoping to get out of it
and um
and you just can't
take it for granted like that there's
not every guest is every guest is the
same some are more recognizable some are
here more often but culturally this we
want people to have this experience and
it's a tight rope between
formality and comfort and
it's not always so easy um but that's
the goal and so far we've been okay at
it great
how much of your business do you think
is word of mouth and referrals of people
who have come here experienced a culture
and that's what they end up talking
about 100 100 yeah
nobody comes here because they think i'm
such a nice guy
maybe the first time they come but
certainly nobody comes back because of
that and so what do you think the words
are that they're using so 100 of your
business referral based they had a great
experience here
what is
that celebrity or just that person
i think it's different for everybody i
think the words they say is you got to
go to hump fish they're the coolest
place okay i think it's uh we've
developed a name that
has a
certain
perception of very good quality food
very good quality experience
and a really neat fun place to go like
it's a formal place where you go out
laughing that's sort of the goal and um
and i think it's a little different for
everybody the crowds are different if
midweek is different than weekend lunch
is different than dinner so i think
there's no one theme that appeals to it
but i think the overall is like you got
to go to hunt and fish club one of the
more interesting things we were once
named in a rap song okay and you
probably could tell i'm not a real big
rap guy
there was an artist named little uzi
vert okay talked about
doing something really cool and taking
your girlfriend or whatever to the
hunting fish club in and of itself
that's cool yeah part b of the story is
he's never actually been here okay he
just knows he just knows and it has a
yeah the branding yeah it's great
yeah i thought that was pretty
fascinating actually if you had to pick
three to five adjectives
that would make you the most proud if
you heard people talking about your
restaurant what would you say
first i have to remember what an
adjective is
i haven't been in school in a while
i'll tell you the thoughts number one is
the first thing that people
talk about is when you walk in it's got
a very impressive look to it you came in
today and you said wow this place is
gorgeous yeah i'm very proud of if i
showed you the renderings
when this place was just an idea
uh the artist's renderings and what it
looks like they're identical so we built
exactly what we wanted
number two is
that when they were here they were made
to feel comfortable immediately
number three is that they got everything
out of the experience that they had
hoped
number four is that they tell their
friends about it and number five is that
they friends then show up
like for example the other day we had a
holiday party um
and
there were some things that happened
during the party that internally we knew
weren't
what was supposed to have happened the
timing was a little off um
not only did the guests not know it the
company the host uh it was a corporate
event the host went into our office
afterwards and said he wanted to pick
his night for next year wow
notwithstanding like i'm sitting there
obsessing about the few things that
weren't exactly the way i had planned
right but that's us knowing the way this
was supposed to play out
your
nobody micromanages it
as a guest the way you do as
the owner or the management
like what does the guest know the food
wasn't good or my guest had to wait a
half an hour to refill their drink that
they see and that's a problem
the little things
i see it
and the staff hopefully sees it
but the guests don't always it's more
about they have a global experience
either i had a really good time or i
didn't right right they don't worry was
that french fry a little burnt right
it's just not a lot like i care
but they don't so you want them to have
a global experience that's either
positive
or you want it to be positive it's
either going to be positive neutral or
negative neutral and negative is not
acceptable
um
good enough is never good enough
right like there's good and there's not
good
right there's no such thing of
it's good enough the same whether it's
employees whether it's the food
is good enough there's just not a
concept i don't even know what it means
like good enough for what
like
you're either goody or not and the goal
here is you got to be good
you got to be really good and so
culturally you want
the staff to know because the
the staff
the way they feel they're the ones who
put the culture on to the guests
the guests will have their experience
based on your staff and how they present
everything else the room is already
built that doesn't change with some
nights it's laid out differently
depending on what's going on but the
basics it is what it is
the staff kind of create the
feelings within the room that the guests
then feed off of
and
um and that doesn't happen randomly or
by accident you point it out you have
classes you show
this is what we're trying to do here
um and either they get it or they don't
and hopefully they do and it's
we have a staff that is
perhaps on the younger side
and a little less formal but that's not
an accident i could
if i wanted i could go hire people who
have been serving formal steakhouses in
the last 40 years and are very rigid and
very formal and i'm not criticizing and
that that's fine it's just not what we
wanted here we wanted a little we wanted
some of that feeling but in a more
casual friendly way
and it's again it's in our case it's
walking a tightrope but it's walking a
tie rope that we've sort of mastered and
we're pretty good at it and there's some
mess-ups obviously this is not a
it's not buying a comic book at a candy
store where they're all the same every
night is different
and
there's just a lot of moving parts
but overall there's an experience that
we're trying to create so getting back
to the original concept of culture
all of this is a culture and every staff
member knows what the culture is
supposed to be
you just you feel it in the room you
feel
a vibrancy a vibe comfort dinner tonight
i hope you feel it um
rather than quiet people whispering in
their own little universe you feel a
certain energy of
people are at their own tables but
they're in this room together
and that's a great feeling
and
hopefully
hopefully we get it every night
we are talking about how to have success
in the restaurant industry this is part
three we're talking about the importance
of branding and marketing
this is one of the tough ones everybody
has an idea to start a restaurant but
how do you get it out there how do you
get business coming in
what advice do you have if i was really
good at that i'd have a lot more i don't
know
let's think this through um no as we
mentioned earlier in
the one of the other segments is you
have to have an idea of who your
audience is
and um
and how to target them and how to get
them to know you exist
and whether it's word of mouth whether
it's paid advertising
there has to be and i and i don't think
there's a
right or wrong answer i think that you
um you just have to know going in that
you have this is the audience you're
trying to reach and have an idea of how
to reach them
if it's a neighborhood pizza place then
it might be a really big neon sign that
flashes in their window at two in the
morning right right but that's marketing
right so this it's the same thing here
and um
i'm probably the worst marketing guy in
the world i'm the worst self-promoter
when i practice lore i was horrible at
doing that
um
but it's
that's not a feather in my cap it's it's
a weakness that i had to go outside and
get people who understood this much
better than i did
um the everything is marketing serving a
good meal over a bad meal is marketing
because word of mouth
it's great advertising right doing
being good at what you do is
marketing um
going out and
talking to people
um like hand door-to-door hand-to-hand
um mentioning it all the time is all
marketing stuff that you don't
necessarily think about marketing i
talked to an old college friend and i
said guess what i have a restaurant in
new york
i'm partly i'm saying it because i
haven't seen them in a while come hang
out with me partly it's marketing like
they got all over
so everything is sort of marketing
um the look and feel of the restaurant
is marketing like we spend a good amount
of money making this place look the way
it looks
i would rather spend less
right
certainly i spent money i didn't have to
get it to look like this that's i know a
different class um
but it's all predicated on
uh promotion of some sort
i guess in my mind and like i said it's
far from something i do well it's i just
look at it that everything we do around
here is in its own way marketing
having
a famous person sitting at this table
and having that table recognize them is
sort of marketing right um
with the more formal things i've learned
all about this social media thing i am
way too old to be learning about social
media marketing i don't get it
i think i use facebook to find people
who
uh are you're on youtube right now on
youtube i don't even know what the hell
youtube is but i like you you're a good
guy
okay so what do you recommend so
somebody
if you don't have the expertise if
you're if you're introverted you're shy
is it do i only you know i'm gonna focus
on client experience and that's it don't
is it hire people to help me
recognize that it has to happen
and create a strategy to make it happen
whether it's higher whether it's
partners whether it's to go out of your
comfort zone right whether it's to go
door-to-door to the office building next
door handing out flyers come see me i'll
give you a free drink so what did you do
as a shy introverted guy what did you do
to get the marketing if it's not yours
forte i have really well known partners
who are really good at this okay
um
what i've
and they got us sort of on the map like
when we opened their doors we had a
target audience and i
i'm part of my own target audience in my
professional life my other professional
life so i understood what it is about
this place that i would have liked as a
customer which is always a good thing
it's like treat yourself as a customer
and see if you like it
uh the answer better be yes the
but i had well-known partners who have
um
uh an ability to reach out
and be recognized and that helped um
early on we had some
tv personalities with huge social media
followings so it's funny but we were
open maybe two or three weeks and we
were slowly gaining traction
this would have been
maybe february of 2015 we'd been open
since january
and there was somebody here from a
popular show i'm not sure if i'm
supposed to mention which one so i won't
but it was a popular show and he was a
well-known guy on this show
with the huge social media following
with an emphasis on food and he ordered
a seafood tower and took pictures of it
and put it out in the world of social
media whatever i didn't understand the
whole concept i'm driving home that day
i have one of my other partners
send me a text that we're trending i
don't even know what that meant okay
like that'd be trendy i was like to me
trendy meant bell bottoms i don't know
what trendy meant trending
within
days there was two and three hour waits
at our bar wow and i could draw a and we
had done other social media the one time
in our life we actually hired a a pr
from right at the beginning was for a
handful of months and was to get the
local new york magazines and papers to
come visit taste do little stories about
us and that was cool and that lasts like
i said about a few months right and
either catches on or it doesn't um
so
when i say to answer one of the earlier
questions was there a strategy i guess
that's a strategy
i i had never experienced it enough to
know would this work or not work or just
didn't know
um
i don't recogni i don't recommend going
into this blind sort of like i did
but because of my partners i didn't feel
totally blind
and after that
personality put us out there and we
started trending like i said then we had
two three hour waits
which we weren't prepared for i ended up
giving away as much food as i sold
because people were having a lousy time
like it was great to have a two or three
hour wait but people don't like waiting
three hours right right and especially
not if they're sitting at a table and
like we went from i wouldn't say from
zero to 60 within from let's say 20 to
60 like within two or three days we were
very ill equipped and but eventually we
figured it out and um
and so it was all done through and that
actually was the first time that i
experienced the power of social media
like homework like that was no joke
the thing that comes to mind for me and
that is in our last episode you talked
about culture and you treat everybody
who comes in like their vip and here's
this guy who like you have no idea who
he is maybe but he still felt like a vip
well he other people knew who he was
okay they looked at me and like i said
this is who he is like okay okay right
but even it's like okay even though it's
not
no
he's you're still a vip you still get
treated as such right and he reacted
right because if he didn't he wouldn't
have done that right presumably sure um
i don't know maybe he gets some benefit
out of it because he looked at this
place and go i need to affiliate with
them i don't know what's in his thought
process but clearly if it was awful
one of two things would have happened
either he'd have done nothing or he'd
have done it in reverse like i'm at this
restaurant it's horrible it sucks right
right right that wouldn't have been so
good it could have been trending but
you're not the wrong way i suppose um
so yeah he clearly had had a very good
experience and he's come back
since several times and always does that
and i'm not sure the impact anymore
because
it's the same people who see it over and
over i guess i don't know but
we definitely do see
that and i learned what influences are
right there you go all right
so for entrepreneurs who want to get
into the restaurant business and they
feel like they're introverted and and
shy i'm going to do the ops and want to
find partners to do
to support them so many people want to
be a part of the restaurant business how
do i decide
you know if if i'm going to partner on
just to be a
mouthpiece and be you know get out there
and spread the word but not have kind of
day-to-day role how do i decide like who
do i find how much do i give them like
the practical questions that is going to
run through people's rights so that's
more of a
finance and structure
corporate structure type question
um
but
i guess the best answer i could think of
is
recognize this as a need
figure out how the need is going to get
filled
whether it's friends whether it's
partners whether
there's more than one way to fill the
lead right like we've done a few we had
a chef we put them on good morning new
york one day does anybody watch that i
assume so i don't know
but
they
i
i hadn't really thought about it but
when the opportunity came i'm like yeah
that's a good thing um
so
it's not so much as
find a partner who could do it or
not or it's
there are
holes and pegs and you have to figure
out how to fill them all in um
whether it's a chef or whether it's
somebody to get your name like one
without the other doesn't work these are
all the things that have to happen
and just make provisions for it to
happen
whatever way makes sense if you don't
have it take ads out in the local
newspaper i don't know maybe that works
but recognize that somehow people have
to know you're there they have to know
who you are they have to know what
you're serving and what audience you're
appealing to and are they part of that
audience and however you get that
messaging out is fine because it's out
and just know going in it has to get out
i don't think there's a single formula
if you don't know what to do budget a
publicist or a pr firm or somebody like
that and they'll do it for you or guide
you
um
and there are places that specialize in
getting restaurant names out there
look it up do some homework you could
pay for it well that just added to your
opening budget right right which
somebody like me never has enough of an
opening budget right um
but it's
so the short i keep saying the same
thing is it's it's all obtainable
there's a lot of ways to obtain it what
you don't have the luxury of doing is
ignoring it right you have to figure out
how to obtain this
what do you think the biggest marketing
mistake is people do when they're first
just not thinking about it enough not
doing it
we have really good food so people are
going to come a lot of places that have
closed have had really good food i've
gone to some of them they had um james
beard winning chefs and didn't see their
first anniversary their food was great
nobody knew where they were
wrong location
no marketing
just thinking oh well we have this
person or the food drilling so your
food's really good lots of restaurants
have good food why should i go to yours
all right yeah you have to be very
critical of yourself of like yeah people
have x amount of dollars and x amount of
meals they're going to eat
why should they come to you and why
should they spend their
funds on your place and you have to give
them a reason to and there's a lot that
goes into it one of the first thing that
goes into it they have to know about you
right like
it's what good does it do you if after
you close somebody said oh i wish i knew
you were around that doesn't help
so
just
there has to be a strategy there's no
one strategy
right like people win
super bowls on offense and on defense
right you got to do something right
there has to be a reason you're there
right so however you get to the finish
line of this marketing thing you just
have to have it
um
you know maybe if you're
if you're a kiosk in grand central
station you don't because eight million
people come in and out of your front
door every day but apps in a scenario
like that
like we're on a side street we're on a
side street of a relatively busy
neighborhood but we're on a side street
you can't see me from either corner you
have to kind of know we're here
and um and our frontage is not that
large we're a lot bigger on the inside
than we are on the outside
i don't get to do a neon sign i don't
get to do any of that stuff right you're
not going to see me if you don't know me
you're not walking in
so my job is to you to know me
and hopefully people know me
so
that's
like i said the best thing is if
whoever is thinking of doing the
restaurant if they have that ability
themselves it's great if they don't
get it however you get it just get it
welcome back everybody i'm here with
nelson one of the co-founders of the
hunt and fish club here in manhattan new
york and we were talking about how to
build a successful restaurant his 10
tips for success and today we're going
to talk about
funding
so one of the biggest issues a lot of
wannabe restaurant restauranteurs have
to deal with what's your advice so
there's never a problem with funding
there's always problems with lack of
funding okay right that's the easy
answer
um
it's one of the more challenging parts
of getting started
for a lot of reasons the difficulty of
it the
integrity of it
the necessity of it the timing of it
you'd be amazed at how many restaurants
never open their doors because they run
out of money before they get to that
point just on the build
on the build yeah so a lot goes into it
is
how do you structure what does somebody
get for their dollar by way of an
investor what do active partners get or
value-added partners as opposed to
straight money partners
um how to fairly do a budget and
and i can tell you the biggest hurdle
i've had and i've been spending years
dealing with it was being underfunded
when we opened our budgeting was very
good the timing of it was bad it just
took too long for some of the money to
come in
and so you get when you're not getting
it in fast enough you have to slow up
your construction because if people
don't get paid they don't come back
right
um
that delayed openings cost money you
stop paying rent you have staff and
the landlord gets paid whether you're
open or not yours whoever staff you've
hired get paid with you
it's a very vicious cycle if you are
under capitalized everything costs more
than you think i could say in this case
we actually did a really good job of
budgeting and i would have been
within five or ten percent
which i i would pay ten percent to have
been within five or ten percent
um
here and
and whatever shortages are don't go away
you just have to play catch up
for when you're open which is just one
more expense on top of a very thin
margin business to begin with
so
the advice in terms of funding is number
one is
real budget and how do you get a real
budget if you've done this
a lot i guess you know how to do it if
you've never done it or if you've done
it once or
you're now going from let's say a 500
square foot takeout to a 8 000 square
foot sit down you need to
pick everybody's brain be realistic
and think of everything you don't think
of and
it's
it's a big deal um
if i had to do it again i would have one
of the things i didn't want to do was
over finance and take more money than i
actually needed if i had to do it again
that wouldn't have been a concern
um because i had this thing about being
a finance background is like return on
investment and the less i take the less
i have to give them and it's a higher
percentage right and i'm doing all of
this gymnastics in my head
none of which said you wanted to be open
by october because you didn't raise
enough money you didn't open until
january and in new york city october
november december is pretty good money
right opening in january not so good
right and um
and it cost us
between what didn't come in on terms of
because the money didn't come in timely
and having to have slowed down
construction
um
we ended up spending more just because
of the delay and we lost income from
three really good months right
the net effect of that was well north of
a million dollars
just for those three months just for
between
right between additional cost of delay
and
lack of revenues or
it was when i say well north of a
million probably closer to one and a
half million
that i now have to figure out and that
doesn't you don't snap your fingers and
undo a million and a half dollars of oh
right so
we've had and it's been a challenge i'm
still dealing with it yeah like that
never goes away
i mean eventually you'll end up catching
up but it's another million and a half
dollars that wasn't available right all
the time so
um so it has to do with budgeting it has
to do with timing it has to do with
knowing where you're going to get it and
then part b is the morality of it like
restaurants are lousy investments
it's kind of like movies racehorses
stuff like that it's broadway shows
um
first broadway show i was ever asked to
invest in
off the topic i was told the person who
brought it to me that you got to be out
of your mind i saw on the news 88 of all
money is lost
investing in broadway shows which is
still probably better than restaurants
um
and and i told the guy you're crazy we
laughed ha ha the name of that show was
book of mormon okay
oh well
guess what haha was on me right so
but anyway so what i did when i raised
money is i
i i didn't i tried to discard i wanted
people to invest but i didn't want them
to invest more than they were
comfortable okay the
standard question that in one form or
another everybody asked me was how much
should i put in
and the answer was as much as it takes
for you to not care about it for you to
come to the restaurant and just enjoy
yourself and to not affect our
friendship
and if it's anything more than that if
it's going to be enough where you
actually worry like
how we're doing that's not fun that's my
job i need to worry urine
come here have fun introduce people to
say this is my restaurant and all of
that be treated
as if it's your restaurant because it is
when you're an owner you're an owner
someone more some own less but owners or
owners
but if it becomes a stress rather than a
pleasure it's not
you shouldn't do it so
we here have well over 50 investors
um
that i probably could have cut that
number in half maybe less if i would
have pushed for them to do more but i
didn't feel right about doing that um
so my job is to take the pressure none
of those people get
the 3 a.m plumbing call that's my job or
whatever so
um
i suggest that a
people keep that in mind
b they
in terms of how to structure and what
they should get there's a lot of ways to
do it there's equity there's debt
there's convertible debt there's all
kinds of formulas they should go to
accountants or attorneys or advisors who
kind of know the going rate for this
stuff
i know what it is in new york i assume
it's similar elsewhere but i'm really
not positive i think it is
um and then it's limited by your own
uh
by your own discussions and negotiations
do they own part of a brand do they own
a single location like what if there are
four more hunting fish clubs what do the
investors get out of that is it only
this one not and i had to answer those
questions
and again it ties into
economics and
personal integrity
and
[Music]
whatever other factors make sense
and it's not for everybody this is
definitely not an investment for
everybody
the success rate is sufficiently low
that you can't hide that people need to
know that going in
to pretend otherwise would is
you can and there's an ego and people
like it
everyone knows movies lose money right
yet somehow they keep making them right
um
people go into movies because they want
to go sit on a set and have lunch with
jack nicholson i don't know why they do
it right but they certainly don't do
because they think it's a good
investment right they do it because they
want to be in the game yeah so that's
part of why people come to this
but my job isn't to assume that my job
is to try to make them money maybe we
can and maybe we can
but
i'd never look at it like well this
person only gave me x amount of dollars
and it isn't changing their life it's
not my job to determine what money is
important to which investor
my job is to do the best i can to try to
ensure that the place is successful
um
successful in terms of experience
successful in terms of reputation
and successful financially
there are
there are wins in the country right now
which are making it more challenging
frankly
um i think that's all cyclical and it
changes but my investors don't want to
hear
about wages going up or insurance or
real estate taxes it's all true and it
affects how much money we do or don't
make they don't want to hear about it
right
and who are the people who invest in
real estate in the restaurant business
am i going to the bank at all
am i only going to friends am i trying
to find people who
are local who i'm trying to get
introduction to like i want to find my
rest the answer is yes okay
all of them okay get it you have to get
it where you can um
but do the banks like a restaurant
right so unless it's personally
guaranteed forget it correct that's
um you can go to banks after you're up
and running
sure um if you have books and
guess what well they look at your cash
flow they look at your credit card
receipts because a restaurant like ours
it's not cash and all those
concerns of years ago don't really exist
you could pretty much look at my amex
receipts and know how i'm doing yeah it
doesn't it's not that hard if you know
what to look for
but up front now bank funding seems to
be
unlikely unless you're a chain and
there's other things you can point to
um now you go to friends you go to
family you go to people in the area
business people
you go to other people who you know
have invested in other restaurants
previously in this they're out there um
i never thought it was my job to figure
out why
people saw fit to want to invest
my job was to be as honest with them
about the nature of the investment as it
could be
uh as i could be and
i think i did that um
and then
once you're up and running you want to
keep them a prize like you don't take
them for granted and say i'll send you a
statement you'll get a tax return every
year right you want whether it's formal
financial statements or
update emails however it is
um you keep them a prize people should
know if you're giving them information
overload they'll tell you like enough
with that stuff right right but
better that than the other way around
right i made a mistake here i was more
email text than true numbers because i'm
like why do they care how much i'm
spending on linens right
but
i was wrong my investors do care they're
all finance type people
and they look and they some of them
treat every whether they invest 100
million dollars or 50 000 every
investment is its own category and they
want to know what's going on
a few of them are why are you bothering
me with this crap and i don't know about
it and
and when they get on a call about
numbers their only comment is why do we
have an attendant in the mentor
okay i wasn't exactly the purpose of the
call but if that's your question right
you're an investor you're entitled to
know the thought right
so it's just not to take them for
granted um
i like to know what they're trying to
accomplish whether it's make money
whether it's look like a vip in front of
clients whether they think it's cool for
their kids whatever the reason i kind of
want to know because i
want to assure that they get
what it is they invested in whether or
not we make money having said that i
would never ever say look you have 10
reasons to invest in here you've got
nine of them number 10 is you make money
all right so 9 out of 10 isn't bad right
you don't do that like i said earlier i
never ever assume
that somebody's investment doesn't mean
anything to them that's not my job
that's their job right
and so
so that's the biggest thing in
the lesson is who and why right right
what they get for it that's a different
sort of discussion
um
if anybody wants to call me you can go
through evan i'll fill you in on how i
look at it and uh happy to share but
uh there's no magic to it but there is
thought behind it right like if i raise
money for hunting fish two
in theory why do they get vis-a-vis what
hunt and fish one investors right right
a new location but we're already a name
right how do you value it how does it
say it's is that coming hunt and fish
too we working on it i hope so
um there are things pending
um
that i'm hoping happen they're not
totally in my control but yeah that is
certainly the
intent so i don't know it's not part of
funding but
i love the idea of owning a brand more
than i love the idea of owning a
restaurant
and for someone who's starting up a new
restaurant how much
do you recommend them putting everything
on the line so
you know
cashing my 401ks and putting my house up
for a second mortgage and selling
everything if they do that i also
recommend a good therapist okay um so
how do i obviously you have to put in so
i think
that
what i do is i would never ask somebody
to invest in something i don't put up my
own money in right not everyone feels
that that way but i'm also from the
world of investments
okay
so i invest alongside my investors right
i'm not the largest but i'm by far and
away not the smallest either right
not everyone does that or believes they
should do that not everybody is in a
position to do that
um
the
whether or not people are putting their
life
on the line it depends on where they are
in their life i'm
not sure that i could answer that
question easily
if somebody were sitting in front of me
i would
like i would kind of talk it through
with them if you had said i want to do
this okay
all right you have a good likelihood of
hood of success you're personable
you know how to talk to people you have
outreach if it doesn't work where does
that leave you are your kids going to go
to school do you have to move out of
your house
what's next for you and like it's
it's not such an easy
thought process
um it's easier to put yourself out on a
limb if you're younger
when i go back and i speak to kids in
high schools and colleges i like doing
that stuff and i
talk about all the things i screwed up
in my own life in terms of decisions i
made along the way and i give lessons on
what to do by not doing what i actually
did
the younger you are the better it is at
taking risks i wish i had taken more
risks when i was younger and practicing
law i wish i was a client and not the
attorney if i had to do it again um
but
it would be the same thing with this
it's a
question that can't be answered without
a lot more information as to who and
what and what are their choices and
you know if some if somebody was about
to be a first round draft pick in the
nfl yeah do whatever you're gonna you'll
make more it's fine you know if somebody
is a civil service person attorney
like my parents and approaching middle
age
if you leave that what are you gonna
come back to
not so easy
so it's
uh it's a answerable question but not as
a hypothetical it's very specific driven
uh the other part and parcel of that is
do you give yourself a salary when you
open your doors
like do you owe your investors you know
you're going to struggle
do you budget i'm going to pay myself
maybe you have to maybe you have the
luxury of not having to
it's part of
the discussion
right like
i'm here for income i'm not here for
expense but i also have a wife and kids
so they have to you know it's not so
easy
there's always a
medium that makes sense there's always a
trader
and
so while i can't necessarily answer the
question
here at this table
there is answers to this question
and
you have to ask it today we're talking
about location location location
what do we need to know nelson
it's hard
it's really hard
um
there's a reason the larger chains have
location departments right it's not like
let's call a broker and see what's
available
they have scouting they have references
they have demographic studies it's a big
deal the perfect spot is not always
available like when you find a great
location you see somebody else's sign
there not so easy knowing your audience
where are they
like go to them and or can you be a
destination spot where you're so in
demand and you're so unique that they'll
come to you like oh that's a good
example i don't know if you know the
restaurant rios
in spanish harlem
horrible location
they've been there for a long time you
they don't take reservations your people
own their tables you can't get there
it's purely a destination and people
will go out of their way to get there
the most of us aren't that right i'd
like to be that would let me pay less
rent frankly
um so you find a great spot and somebody
else is already there and there were
things you could do about that
you could try to buy them out of their
lease you could wait for their lease to
end you can kind of give up and keep
looking
but a big part of it is in determining
location there's
no such thing as a good or bad location
it's who's your audience there's bad
locations for your audience and there's
good locations for your audience every
location in
the sahara desert is great if you're
selling water and ice cubes there's no
such thing as a bad location it's bad
audience for your bad spot for your
audience
so
the way this place came about is we had
actually
targeted this location for a different
group okay
a different concept
uh it just wasn't available to us at the
time when it finally became available we
said oh we always liked that spot what
would work there
and so that's when we came up with
that we had this other idea based on i
said an earlier conversation of doing a
more slightly more formal
steak and seafood place in new york city
and we said all right that spot would
work so in this particular instance
it wasn't available for what we
initially
wanted to do it became available and
then we figured out what we wanted to do
with it
but in terms of scouting locations
it's
who are you appealing to is it
affordable does it fit within your
budget
yeah i mean we're in a beautiful spot
we're just off of times square
easy to get to your target market's here
if if i'm starting a restaurant and i
know where my audience is let's take
what you just said hold on okay hold
that door okay yeah let's go beautiful
spot we're right off the times square
yeah okay yeah if you're walking into my
into the restaurant if you turn right
you'll see some banks you'll see some
major law firms you'll see the fine if
you turn left you're gonna be see people
dressed as elmo and big bird trying to
get you to take a picture with them for
five dollars right okay okay
that's not my audience so it's not so
clear that it's
this could have been a great location
for a sports bar okay
uh
somewhat upsell diner like it's not so
clear-cut we're in the theater district
but we don't really appeal to theater
people that which is very commonly price
fixed menus get in and out of an hour we
do do some of that right um
but it's not really our so
i walked in i looked to my right and i
saw my target demographic
if i look to my left i open up a
mcdonald's right right so it's yes it's
a good spot it's a side street yeah
because it's a building that's um i
won't get into the lower new york but
i'm not allowed to put big signs and
whatever here uh it's called landmark
it's a bunch of people who have too much
free time on their hands
but that's political and i don't want to
go there yeah um so you see it's a
really good look i don't know maybe it
is
a block and a half away might have been
better given my target okay so super
interesting so if this is an okay
location for you it's not ideal maybe
there's somewhere else if you had to say
in new york city like this is exactly
where i need to be
if this is not exactly it you still
opened up you still had success like at
what point do you say
just go for it instead of waiting for
that spot to open up i
the line my partner or anytime i used
was we can make that work
this is new york city there's no such
thing as perfect these are all decrepit
buildings and they charge a fortune for
it
and they say well
somebody would ask me could you design a
kitchen like no show me your space like
there's a building attached to me on
this side on this side it's like this is
the space i have to work with and i'll
figure it out if i was in the corner of
a mall with an empty parking lot and
build whatever you want i wouldn't have
built this right there's your space
that's where the kitchen is going figure
it out right right and either figure it
out or you can the issue is perfect or
not perfect i don't know what's perfect
if you make a lot of money it's perfect
if you lose money it wasn't so perfect
new york city is unique i suppose um
but
it was for us it was can this work at
this location right and can we overcome
the hurdles and
we have
but for example i think it impacts our
lunch business we're really not in the
right spot for that right because people
for lunch you have an hour an hour and
10 minutes they got to get here order
eat leave and be back at their desk
right for dinner you're not so
constrained right
uh if you're a pre-theater you have to
get in eat and get out yeah
so is it perfect i don't know it worked
we made it work um
we assumed that we understood the
negative we weren't blind it's not like
we figured it out after the fight
i looked to the left and i saw elmo i
got it right right
um
all right when they started with the
women who legally can go topless that
freaked me out briefly okay but we got
beyond that um
so
it's about
if you're in a market
it's knowing what you need to have
um
that's non-negotiable okay right like
our target audience which i had
mentioned earlier and totally fits into
location in terms of who do you want to
come into the restaurant who do you shut
your eyes and visualize yeah what your
typical tuesday night at eight o'clock
looks like who's in there what are they
eating how much are they spending
like what does it look like what does it
sound like what does it feel like
that's what even what it smells like
what kind of place is it it could be
italian it could be greek it could be
america like yeah they're all available
right you just have to sort of figure
out what makes sense um
the ours was media and finance and
things like that banking
so in new york city if you don't know
this sort of a rectangle with that it's
all over new york but particularly from
42nd street to 57th street from third
avenue to broadway everyone sort of
exists in that rectangle so we're in
that rectangle but we're not in the
center of it we're sort of in a tucked
away in a corner of it
so yeah they can get here it's close
enough on a nice day they could walk on
not such a nice day they can't walk it's
certainly not convenient for lunch
because it's in a corner
um
so we kind of figured it could work but
we also understood there would be some
challenges right not everything we
thought happened for example i thought
we could
because we were in that rectangle i
thought we could generate a breakfast
crowd there's very few breakfast places
in new york that work i mean there's
diners to go get an egg and coffee
before you go to work right but there's
very few breakfast meeting places sit
down breakfast yes yeah you know for the
corporate world right i thought we could
create that i was wrong we tried it it
didn't work we stopped doing it
okay
a lot of entrepreneurs have a hard time
starting because they're waiting for the
perfect time and it prevents them from
actually taking action
you got to the point where you say we
can make this work at what point along
the so if you had your you know 100
perfect place
obviously this isn't like 50 or lower
like at what point
is it like a 75 percent perfect and
like so to help people figure out like
when they should press the go button
it's an art not a science you just have
to intuitively know because the other
thing i hadn't mentioned is how much
does it cost to get in sure why are you
starting was it a restaurant before
where you just do some cosmetics make it
look differently and you're good to go
was it a shoe store that has nothing
ventilation right you have to
and is there a place for it like this is
manhattan i can't go out back or uh it's
12 stories over my head right i can't go
up yeah
which is why i have a less than perfect
kitchen right
um
i have to work with what i had to work
with how much does the landlord think
that this little nugget of gold is worth
yeah because he's not running a
restaurant so he thinks this is the best
spot ever of course right because he
wouldn't have bought the building
did you look left and see elmo this
isn't so great it's okay um
so it's
it's kind of a you have to look at
everything
and then make a determination it's not
an ardor it's it's an instinct
any advice on negotiating with landlords
yeah
don't
yeah
i don't know i'm not that smart i'm not
that good at it well so i mean one of
the scary things is you're usually
locked in for a long term lease you know
most times yeah well in theory because
if you don't do a good job negotiating
that long term is it gonna really happen
so what what are some mistakes that
people make
when they're trying to negotiate a lease
i don't i could only really speak from
new york and a couple of other cities
that i've had some experience in is
you have to know the market you have to
estimate what you're going to do in
sales
because
rent is a
line item it's not your biggest line
item it's your it's a line item
if
if you're people what are you paying for
you're paying for it to be pretty are
you paying for foot traffic
which of those things are important to
you
rent if you do it well could be your
cheapest cost like if you have a
fast
food thing right and you have a heavy
street traffic rent is irrelevant like
if where you are just brings you a
parade of people in front of your door
every day
it's not a big deal
on the other hand if you're in a
corner of the universe and nobody can
get to you or whatever it's
you're paying for something that doesn't
exist so a lot goes into it um
and again it's more of an art than a
science uh every landlord overvalues
every landlord
tells you how many people are banging
down their doors right
and it's yes
it's interactive because at the end of
the day whether you like it or not
whether he likes it or not you're his
partner and he's your partner
this question is how much of a partner
right you have to accept the fact that
he's in bed with you and you're in bed
with him he wants you to work there's a
cost for him if you
don't succeed
a bad real estate deal could put you out
of business right and so it's it's
challenging
in in in this kind of environment like a
restaurant is there a
percentage of revenue that it should be
under yeah i'm told it's supposed to be
10. i read that in a book okay i'm
guessing the guy who wrote the book
never ran a restaurant
um i mean in other parts of the world
maybe it's true yeah and ideally in new
york yeah if you could hit 10 that's
great okay um but if i'm over 30 then
if you're i'm not a little over 12
you're you've got a problem okay but and
then it depends on what kind of food for
example you could possibly pay more for
pizza
because your labor is so low right your
food costs are low right you're paying
for location right now like a lot of
people like people don't travel
an hour and a half because they get a
better slice of pizza right they walk
down the street they that smells good
and they go grab a slice right so you're
paying for that
moment right right and you're not paying
the guys who are making the pizza
that's not a lot of them yeah um the you
don't do a lot of revenues and pizza's
not all that expensive
but you don't need to because the food
costs are very cheap your labor is very
cheap you can pay you pay for location
so it's all part of a bigger puzzle so
the number i'm giving you is more like
this kind of a place yeah
but but there's differences got it i am
here at the hunt and fish club in new
york city and this is episode six where
we are talking about how to train and
manage a team we're here with nelson and
we have a special guest as well nelson
quick thoughts training managing a team
what do you got for us the first thing
i'm thinking of is i'm really not good
at that which is why i asked matt to
join us for this segment he is our
sommelier he oversees the service and he
trains and manages far better than i do
and it's important to keep in mind when
you use the word team i didn't tell you
to say that but that's the right word in
the restaurant business this is a team
and if you don't work together it
doesn't work team is the perfect word
for this so i i asked matt to join us
and he graciously did so
so here we are so tell us matt how do we
build a team train them manage them what
do you think uh i mean so
starting from
day one i guess the most important thing
is always hospitality everything's
hospitality oriented so you really have
to figure out what type of an experience
it is that you're trying to provide for
your guests uh what type of a restaurant
it is that you're trying to have whether
that's casual whether it's fine dining
it's always going to start with being
hospitable
and then you sort of build out from
there in terms of your steps of service
like you greet the guest
how many people are touching the table
what type of interaction you're having
with the guest how much information
you're going back and forth
and so that's sort of the foundation and
then you slowly build from there
and
the first thing you do is obviously
product knowledge
before you start getting into the
specifics of how you're going to execute
that
so that starts with the kitchen getting
all of your ingredients down for each
dish so you know the ins and outs of
everything
when a guest has a question
your staff is able to just instantly
give a response and make people
comfortable
the more that you know about all the
product whether it's food or beverage
the more comfortable you're going to be
at a table and the more you're able to
sell
and provide a good experience for your
guests from that point then you sort of
build like what each step is you go
through throughout the course of the
evening so what are some of the
challenges in finding good people
because it's not it's not just you and
nelson is a huge team here that runs
this place how do you find the right
people for your restaurant that's really
the trick i guess is the interview
process finally as soon as we figure it
out
yeah it's i mean you have to
find people who are good at
relating to guests yeah and i mean you
kind of get that usually with an
interview process with anybody right
with whether or not they're good at just
being comfortable in their own skin
um after that it's really just sort of
follow through and you have to really be
observing with somebody so in the
interview like what are you looking for
what what what's your favorite question
or what are you kind of trying to get
out of them
i mean for for a restaurant especially
when you're on the higher end i like to
ask people where they like to go to eat
what do they like to do what are their
experiences what do they point out
because people who really enjoy it for
the most part usually you find people
who like to go out as well and
like to share those experiences and
so the more that somebody really enjoys
those experiences themselves and what
they're able to provide and sort of
relay those things because you're also
constantly learning okay um so i love
asking people like what do they like to
eat what are the types of foods they
like um so if i say like mcdonald's and
i'm mcdonald's i'm sorry you're not out
[Applause]
yeah and are you looking more for
are you looking more for the type of
food they like are you looking more for
the experience that they get in that
right the experiences they get right why
do you like it right and even if you
like the simplest foods of mcdonald's
there's a thing it's like what is it
about that that you like the consistency
is it that you like that specific
mcdonald's that you frequent all the
time has like a smiling cashier behind
that like you like to go and see right
what is it about the experience that you
can then translate and relay right um so
you look for that obviously you look for
people with with product knowledge uh
who have experience but also people who
are ear to learn right um because you
want people who are open and are willing
to adjust because even if let's say
you've worked at a three michelin star
restaurant and you move to another one
it doesn't mean that the systems are the
same and that you interact the same way
with those types of guests you have to
be flexible and willing to learn because
everybody functions a little bit
differently yeah
so so step one is you know i'm putting
up my job ad or
help on it or whoever you're getting it
out people come in they send their
resume you do your interview
okay i kind of like this person
what's next
hey you kind of like this person so you
bring them in usually what you'll do is
uh if
you're going to bring them on and want
to see them trail on the floor so you'll
provide them with a packet so you'll get
a manual these are steps of service
these are all our guidelines et cetera
et cetera and then after that
you give them a menu and
first things first is going to be the
food you have to learn the food right
and so we usually have them do a trail
in the kitchen okay and you sit there
with a menu and so you see as many items
come out and if you have questions about
those things you can ask
our chef in particular is very open and
always willing to help and explain
if you have any questions about anything
and so
that's sort of your responsibility there
to start looking at everything in detail
and making sure that you know those
dishes you can take pictures of
everything and that's on a typical night
like this it's a night you got people
here yeah if it's i mean the busier the
better if you're starting on the trail
like that because you get to see more
food come out right and am i am i
customer facing at this point yeah at
this point no right it's training
yeah you're just watching everything uh
once once you've done all that then yeah
you start trailing on the floor you're
still not really interacting with
customers you're just following uh you
might help with clearing uh clearing
some tables helping to reset some tables
but you're really not interacting with
customers yet you're seeing how the flow
of service goes right how these people
work
um and then from there uh you kind of
follow through in terms of training
where once you go through food you go
through beverage right if you have a
wine list you want to make sure that
they know everything on the wine list
their cocktail menu
everything that you're serving like all
product knowledge you want to get in
before so ideally you're looking at a
two week process at least depending on
where you are how in depth
and how often do you think people flame
out through that process
uh i mean pretty frequently you usually
want to do a a larger hiring like half
80
no no i mean it's not that high usually
like let's say you hire like five at one
time you might lose one oh that's not
always one or two yeah so you do a lot
of a lot of the up front is in that
face-to-face meeting in the interview
yeah and then you can see and then once
they're they're ready to go on the floor
it's it's a lot of follow-through so i
mean it's a lot of effort and a lot of
work to hire so you don't want to be
constantly just hiring piecemeal you
want to hire at once maybe even have
different times during the year that
you've plotted out when you would like
to hire yeah based on your sales so like
at this point of the year let's say
we're going to get really really busy in
november december so then by september
you want to hire those people and have
them up ready running all through
october so that once it picks up they're
ready to go and you have them already um
because you don't want to
start hiring on the fly right hey this
is trying to get an order
by late november or december they have
to exist on automatic right like they
can't fully spend time for thinking
there's no time for teaching yeah and
it's pretty common you'll have a you
just have a trail with or you'll have a
mock service right
with management whatever management team
you want to have yeah and you put
somebody sort of through the ringer make
sure they're ready to go
and then you can put them on the floor
and give them a smaller section on their
own give them a couple of tables and see
how they handle that and then are you
like you got your eye and you're
watching them yeah i mean you have to so
you have to invest in these people to
make sure they're doing well for you if
the customers like frowning you might
step in and just say how are you doing
we actually have people on the floor who
among everything else they're doing they
actually look at like if you see a
customer kind of like looking around
right his waiter's not there right
yeah like that right and you have to
head over there right so yeah people on
the job it is just to see what's going
on got it right and then
in this kind of business most of the
wait staff are not going to be lifetime
employees for you
right so like how long does somebody
stay or how long do you want my life's
on mine there's at the restaurant yeah
right yeah realize we're talking right
like it may not be a full-time career
they've got other stuff going on sure
yeah some are some aren't um i mean for
us in particular we do have a lot of uh
professional white staff okay because it
is on the higher end so i mean you make
a really solid living it's not
so how long do you want to keep somebody
for like i mean you want to keep someone
as long as possible when they're they're
valuable to workouts yeah it could be
like there's a reality of having to say
there's a value that customers come in
and see the faces they recognize right
yeah you don't want a constant turnover
if you could avoid it right
for example we i mean we have some white
staff who have been with us since we
opened right and this is what they do
this is the profession right really
really good at it they take a lot of
pride in their work yeah and you can
tell because there's guests that
haven't been here but maybe have had
them serve them somewhere else
previously okay and then they get
excited when they see them right right
and they already have this rapport with
them and they get really yeah they
already get excited and they're like oh
my gosh so good to see you have you been
are you in your section tonight that'd
be great right um there there's a nice
quality to having people like that now
again like you said you're not going to
have everyone be that way but the
important thing is that the people that
are not here for the long haul are still
dedicated while they're here right it's
like yes you might have something else
that you're doing on the side whatever
that may be whether you're in the
performing arts yeah or a student
uh
the point that you have to make clear
with the staff is while you're here
there are people who this is their
livelihood right and this is what they
take pride in yeah and you have to be on
the same level or at least striving to
be at the same level while you're here
once you're out the door it's whatever
you want to do right if you're here
three days a week four days a week it
doesn't matter you still have to be up
to par right and you have to be thorough
with that it's very difficult i think
sometimes because you can be really
compassionate about somebody else's
plight and how difficult that can be um
especially when this isn't what they're
dedicating their life to right at the
end of the day this is a business that
you have put everything into and
especially as an owner yeah uh you have
to be
a little bit
i guess not harsh but pretty strict in
terms of what you will or won't allow
when it comes to someone like that and
then for the people who do
want to take it as your career how do
you like why why come here why not why
not go somewhere else like how do you
keep them to stick for
a long time i mean that's the trick
right
what do you do that's so different in
your culture or like or in the training
or in the follow-up or just the care or
the humanness or the charity work like
why why would somebody stick with you
when they could get the same wage
somewhere else right why stay here
one of the if i could enter one of the
challenges when you first open up
is that so few restaurants survive it's
actually very hard to get people
in the beginning because why would you
leave a restaurant that's up running
established i'm making a living and it's
fine yeah chances are nine out of ten
they're not going to see an anniversary
so in the beginning while we do have
some people who've been here since day
one
by and large you turn over your initial
staff
because of the better
career people aren't going to leave
where they are in the beginning
but then like anything else once you get
more established and whatever happens
people get ready for a switch and it's
out there
perhaps their restaurant closed perhaps
they have a different manager there's a
million reasons
but the fact is you can find people
the hard part is in the beginning
because who knows if you're going to
make it once you're up and established
people want to work for you that's okay
but
yeah i mean that's a good point it's
it's especially in the beginning it's
really difficult
um and it's it's fostering an
environment that
is i guess really open in terms of
uh information flow so you want to
always be available and open to your
staff if they have questions yeah and
you want to instill that in the people
that you work with you want them to be
curious about product and product
knowledge and about what they're serving
uh so there's ways of incentivizing the
staff as well with that like we'll have
sales competitions for different
products
and a lot of wineries are always like uh
willing to sort of help out with that a
little bit uh okay um and they'll come
in and do a staff training okay um and
so that you get the background on let's
say a story of a particular winery or if
it's a new whiskey producer or whatever
it might be and so it gets the staff
jazzed up about it and then we can set
aside one bottle of something whoever
sells the most of that at the end of the
month i think we can gift that to them
right got it um and so it's it just
makes it a little bit more fun a little
more exciting and it makes people want
to learn a little bit more right about
what they're selling right
and i'm also curious about
your role and what you've learned from
nelson too and that we've been doing
this series
and
and this series is meant to be me and
the founder and when we've done before
it's always been the founder and
nelson's like i love it but i want to
bring in my team for some of the
episodes right like how do we make it so
that i can bring in my team because i
want them to get recognition and growth
opportunity all that stuff so
that was a that's a rare request
what i do right and so it's great having
you here i'm curious like how you feel
having a mentor who's who's helping
guide you or what you've learned from
him before you answer let me just have
learned a lot more from him
and all that but
you could be anywhere you know you chose
to be here you chose to be part of the
leadership team you're building your
career here
you know what does that feel like or
what have you learned from nelson
wherever you want to take that question
uh i mean as far as having with the
ownership here what's really great is
that
they know what they want to provide in
terms of a guest experience but they do
give us the rings they really allow us
to structure that and build it which is
huge and so we have to learn a little
bit from our own mistakes and
nelson's really good at stepping in when
it's really really necessary okay but
he's
also good at being hands off and being
open in terms of things he doesn't
necessarily know about the business like
in terms of financials and stuff like
that i can still sit with him for hours
on end like every single day for like
the next few years i'm not going to know
anywhere near no bike
as much as he knows but when it comes to
things like steps of service or dealing
with customers
dealing even with an irate customers
ways the two
modify situation like that yeah
he's open to ideas because we're the
ones that are here on the floor every
day dealing with those types of what's
one thing that you brought that was
different or your idea that you were
able to implement that now is kind of
you've rolled out to the rest of your
team that i've rolled out for the rest
of the team here
let's see different in terms of
anything like you came in and he was
here's how you run a restaurant and
you've learned something from nelson but
then you're you're on the floor you're
dealing with people
you're in the front lines and you come
up with a strategy or solution or a way
to appease guests that's like i think i
think that can work and then that you've
now taught
the rest of the people on your team how
to do it and i could interject the thing
that jumps
he's got it okay
the
beverage program we had on day one
was zero like there was no beverage
there was no thought there was no
anything
he came in and lent an entire level of
expertise
to the beverage in terms of back of the
house structure accounting inventory
to the front of the house product
product knowledge sales and so now you
can talk about yeah but that's the one
that jumped right out of me like oh like
people actually know how to do this
right right yeah i mean i don't know
that it would be necessarily anything
different outside of the the industry
but different in terms of how we were
functioning uh definitely just bringing
a little bit more structure as uh
how it was initially being run
in terms of training the staff on what
they're actually selling instead of just
here's a book of
200 wines yeah good luck right
right and then you just hope that people
know what it is if they have questions
they don't know now grammy we've
expanded the list really close to 800
bottles now and it's um still it's not
that the largest list
in the city by any means
but the staff knows a lot more about
that list than they knew about the 200
bottle list when i first got here
um and they're also more eager to dive
into it and sort of
interact with guests so i mean the
people watching are people who are
trying to get into the restaurant
industry are curious about it if you had
a final message around
hiring people
or training them or keeping them what
would
that final message be uh it would be i
mean first things first is know what
kind of experience it is that you're
trying to provide and that'll really
guide the type of people that you get in
uh because if you're having a place
where it's really hands off and it's
everything is very quiet very like white
tablecloth and you don't necessarily
need a lot of personality at the table
then that's going to guide you to the
type of person you need you can have
somebody who's a little bit more stoic
and really good at
being sort of methodical in their
process right whereas if you're having
somewhere that's like loud and need
really boisterous people it's gonna need
somebody who has a little bit more
personality isn't comfortable in that
situation just really knowing the type
of person that you want
on your restaurant floor and after that
it's just follow through it's a lot of
follow-through with your staff
after you've put in the work and given
them all the tools that you can because
at the end of the day it's on them
whether or not they want to continue to
do that but you do have to oversee that
this is video number seven and we are
talking about how to create an
interactive customer experience
nelson what do you think
i don't know
yeah
so when you talk about customer
experience it's not as we've discussed
in the earlier
discussions
it's not only about the quality of the
food though that's
important perhaps the most important
function it's the experience starts when
they open the front door
they get greeted somebody takes their
coat they're sad or they're
brought to the bar for
to wait for a few minutes and have a
drink but that's all part of the
customer experience it's not just at the
table it's really from the time they
open the front door until they close it
behind them
and it's all part of the i won't call it
a broadway show but it's like a broadway
show everybody has a role and if any
part of that
production doesn't work it impacts
adversely the entire production
uh if literally if it takes too long for
somebody to get their coat when they're
ready to leave that's what they remember
that's enough yeah because
that's last experience was not a good
one so it's very much interactive and
it's not just about the table it's about
everything that goes on
now you've got a special guest
nova he's been with us for a while and i
brought her because she's spectacular
and is better at this probably than
anybody we have oh well thank you nelson
um like i haven't told you that before
so what's the secret nova
listen
i don't know if there's really a secret
and as cliche as it might sound um
fundamentally i think it boils down to
being empathetic
to your customers experience
what are you looking for when you come
into a restaurant what kind of service
are you looking for what kind of an
evening are you looking for you have
customers that come in here that are
regulars and they come in and sometimes
they just want to come in and they just
want to be served
and you know they want to come in and
have their dinner and want everything to
go smoothly and it is your job and
your responsibility to make that happen
and then there are other customers that
are looking to create an experience and
then again it falls on you to help them
you know they come into the restaurant
they don't know what they want to eat
maybe they feel a little bit intimidated
the restaurant's large there's so many
people it's loud and it is your job to
make them feel like they are at home and
they're being taken care of
um
whether that's something as small as
noticing something at the table
you know as small as
someone who doesn't want a lime in their
beverage and the first time you bring
the beverage over and they take out the
lime then the next three times you bring
the beverage over you're not going to
put a lime because you know that they
don't want that lime
it's these little things that if you
take notice
the customer i think has a better
experience because you're really
wanting them to have the best experience
um and really wanting to do the best you
can to do that and so yeah
empathy is big one for me i'm a very
empathetic person i'm lucky enough to
have grown up on the being served side
okay because i have parents who and my
family who like to live a certain way
and they like to go out for dinner and
so i was always on the other side um and
for me to be on this side i really
it is important for me
to have people leave and feel like
they're they want to come back feel like
they were taken care of they had a great
evening they had great food and
they will remember forever that small
little thing that maybe someone
remembered on the bean serve side were
there ever
were there a couple of servers that
stand out as
this person gave me a remarkable
experience
i think
yeah servers but funnily enough more
just establishments and i think that's
the point is to make the establishment
and to work as a team we mentioned
earlier that team is really important
and i agree 100 right um
not looking it as a paycheck but more as
what you can do to make even someone's
night just nicer
and um the biggest ones that jump out of
me i think are all in europe but
in italy specifically um there's this
little
little seafood restaurant in sardinia
near albia where we where we have a
summer house and it's this little shack
that serves grilled fish but
every time we came in they remembered my
grandparents names they remembered my
name i met them maybe two times they
remember my whole family they remember
what we had for dinner a year ago they
remember the wine we like to drink and
it when we go there for dinner it's like
a family event and it's a very very nice
familiar feeling to go somewhere where
you feel like
family yeah
what are some of the tells or things
that you're really trying to pay
attention to that you've maybe honed
over the years where if you see your you
still you said the line right
if you see your actually stole that from
our gm okay
but it was something that i never
forgotten it's something that i really
have taken into account like when i
first started here i didn't think
something that small could change
someone's experience and then after you
know he used it as an example and it
became an example
in the way i work as well noticing small
things like
um
i mean i don't know any anything from
even the swivel of the head if someone's
not there quick enough you want to just
make sure that you anticipate their
needs before they feel like they need
something
um
i think really that is what it is and
and helping each other out you see
someone who maybe cannot get to a table
and that person is
a little bit exasperated because they
want to order because they got a show to
get to and you make it a point to to
make sure that they don't feel that
worry
do you
have any favorite questions you'd like
to ask your clients like are you asking
them why they're here are you asking
this the first time you're asking what
they're doing tonight is there
i don't i
i have some i'm very talkative with my
tables
um
i think really it's i don't want to have
a script that when i go to a table i say
the same thing to every table you know
you talk about yeah you have your thing
about your the way you talk about a menu
i have my steps that i go down with
talking about the money but really every
table i want it to be individual i want
each table to be able to leave and i say
like i will remember them when they come
back and they will remember right so
it's a
it's a it's hard to express but there's
just
either have it or you're not there's
just an intuition of what a table
expects from you
in turn and you just get a feeling for
it how they're looking at you whether
they're fidgeting whether they're
relaxing
do you want them do they want you to
stay a few extra seconds do they want
you to don't come over so much you're
bothering us right right and nobody will
ever say don't come over you're
bothering me or nobody will say hang out
we like we love you
right but you just kind of get a sense
for it if you've done it long enough and
if you're good enough
you just sort of know right and
and that's a big part of it
so
i guess the logic behind the question
was how do we train more novas right
it's like how do you have how do you
take what is amazing and then
and then give people if it was so easy
don't you think i would have done right
well i'm helping you here
like we haven't thought of that
um
don't i don't i don't know i don't think
that um
yes no so i just want to go down
different path that sparked
empathy
how do you
put aside your crazy day and crazy life
and everything else that is happening
and
for a lot of the people here and running
a restaurant is ridiculously crazy
business
how can you put aside all of that and
have empathy for the person like you got
a million things to deal with how do you
how do you put that aside and have
empathy for the person in front of you
i think that's very i mean it's just
that it's you've had a crazy day and
you're not feeling like serving a table
but what about that table who came in
maybe
they had a crazy day i had a table that
came in the other night and they came in
as a you know a couple and they came in
for dinner husband and wife and
i came to learn that their daughter just
had a car crash so i'm like whatever
whatever i'm dealing with doesn't matter
because you're there and you're ready to
work and you don't have
your life
interfering anymore because now it's
about their experience not yours
i remember reading the study about these
seminary students
they were training to become priests
and they had to they had to do us
a speech on
our sermon on giving back and and
helping people who were in need
and
they put a homeless person right outside
where they were supposed to leave
and when they gave them an hour to get
to their lecture
the priest and trainer would almost
always stop and help that homeless
person when they were rushed and only
had five minutes to get across campus
they almost never stopped
so like you're the kind of person who
would stop
and so it's how do you identify that and
if you can't train it then how do you
find it in people
so that
you bring those because that's what you
want right like you want the priest who
you want the nobody's when the priest
will stop even though you know even just
that five second interaction with the
homeless person might spark his day and
you still get off and do your thing that
seems to me like the restaurant industry
you've got all these tables to wait it's
crazy so this problem's happening yeah
not the answer for nova but it starts
out with people
not the answer for how about our lives
the person you bring here starts their
day that
their goal it's not about what happened
to them before and that yes we all bring
our baggage with us when we come to work
but they're they're here to focus on
that customer like that's what they're
here for right so it's not like how do
you train them for that's all they're
here for right if they're not here for
that
then they probably won't last very long
right so it's sort of it's not a thought
because that's already on automatic or
it should be
like nova doesn't think about oh what
like
i have to focus on them today that's
automatic
she's here she does
and
uh again to make her
to blow her head up
um
we once had a cnbc talk show host uh
comment he was sitting with some
ownership group from the washington
redskins and he was he's a friend of
mine and he's so stressed out
and um and he goes i want everything to
be perfect this is a really important
dinner for me and an important meeting
for me and all of that so i asked nova
to serve the table
when it was all said and done and he was
about to go home he said i won't say
nova is the best server you've ever had
here okay i would say she is the best
server i've ever experienced in my
entire life wow
wow and i'm not making that off the show
i've told her and
yes and so then how do you deal with
with your own
you're so busy helping other people and
being empathetic to them how do you deal
with your own
issues that's my excuses like i'll just
deal with it
and not deal with my own um i don't know
i don't i actually don't know how to
answer that i don't think that that is
how i think at all i don't think how do
i deal with their problems if i can't
deal with my own i just
i mean really nelson said it right it's
on autopilot it's part of your job yeah
simply put that's it and how you wish to
carry that out is up to you and that's
also what makes everyone's experience
different you know
um
each server brings something different
to the table
and i think that put together when when
everyone works together and everyone
wants to be there and is not just
looking at this place or any place
really just as a paycheck then you have
feeling and
feeling is a big part of it
we have
obviously many servers
and many good servers and they don't
have to say like there's no right way to
do her their job like has her way right
we have other very good servers who are
like cartoon characters but people like
them it's
they have different personalities and
different ways of going about it
but what's the consistent theme is
making everyone feel important being
sensitive to
their verbal cues their nonverbal cues
they they kind of if you watch and if
you're sensitive to it they're telling
you what the experience
they expect to have is or they hope to
have
and it's our job to exceed it
one of the things we did here is like
we're very big on vips everyone's a vip
but we have we get a list of vips who
are start out as vips they don't become
vips before they walk in and we have a
knife with their name on it as part of
that make them feel really special right
and so they're all happy and giddy and
just seeing their name on their own
knife that they didn't use right
like it puts them in a good mood when
they're in a good mood my job job is
easier our job is easy everyone's job is
easier because they're already happy
right well not everyone has an obviously
so their job is to put them all in a
good mood like this is hospitality
people want to have fun yeah and so it's
their job to figure out what it takes
for them to have
that experience
and so nova started off talking about
empathy being her superpower
is that from your perspective nelson
would you say that that's a that's a
hunt and fish club superpower that's a
nova superpower that she brings
her more than others
um
but it's my job as
an owner
to make sure that
everyone brings that same thing to the
table
some form of it
yes whether they think of it that way or
not and
nova is very professional and thinks it
through maybe even more than some others
probably more than i do and
but at the end
we expect customers to
have a very high quality experience
whether nova is their server or not
um anyone who looks like they're going
through the motions and not really
trying to think it through
that gets exposed very quickly the other
servers know who would who they are the
other managers know who they are
it's not hard to see when you're here
every day
that's all so yes do i wish everybody
would have what nova has
no kidding
best server of all time anywhere and not
by a random like right no he's been out
to he's probably he's every night yeah
for sure yeah if you had a final message
for people who are starting a restaurant
and they're
trying to figure out how to create a
great customer interactive experience
what would you say
don't lose the feeling you know it's
very i see it happened i've seen it
happen with my parents companies i've
seen when things expand really big
big and kind of just go really quickly
it's easy to get caught up in the
um
logistics rather than
fundamentally what we're saying about a
customer's experience you know you start
going into the food and this and that
and this and everything has to be
structured and
don't lose the feeling there's a reason
why you're there one of the earliest
segments was every day there's somebody
coming in here who's never been there
before
joe the magic and they have to get that
same experience they don't know that we
were good yesterday nor does it matter
yeah right you have to bring it every
day
yeah i love it thank you for sharing
thank you for having me this is episode
eight and we're talking about how to
create a culinary experience
nelson your thoughts man
that's thank you
so i brought him out here because i
don't know how to do that
that's back
he was here two episodes ago on how to
uh train and manage your team
what do you think man
i mean providing a good culinary
experience
is
i mean give the people what they want is
what comes to mind in terms of
food this food is very personal um and
so everyone's tastes are different
everyone likes different things uh for
us personally here at hunter fish club
uh our food is pretty classic we don't
really go outside of the box too much
but there's obviously a focus on high
quality ingredients served to you in
a very uh i guess comfortable way like
the dishes that we have don't really
pull anyone too far outside of their
comfort zone okay um and so
with that
comes a little bit of ease to a lot of
guests who come in because we do provide
this sort of high end ambiance yeah but
we're not doing uh what we like to call
tweezer food okay everything is like
really like routinely plated
right okay yeah because i guess it comes
with the idea of saying club right so it
is a club so you want to feel
comfortable at home right while still
having a nice high-end experience right
so that can be as simple as you're
coming in and having a salad and a steak
and that's all you want to do or if you
really want to go all out we have people
you can do a giant shellfish tower uh
with
oysters lobster crab
all the works and then you move into
pasta courses with fresh shaved truffles
yeah and then you can get like an a5
wagyu steak or something if you want you
know right so you can do this really
high end line but at the same time those
are really high-end quality ingredients
but none of it is really so outside of
the box that you're you're making
somebody who's not necessarily
adventurous right and in the culinary
portion of their life the uh not making
them uncomfortable right they're still
really comfortable while having this
sort of lavish experience
um i think that's been an interesting
theme throughout our entire conversation
all the episodes where like you nelson's
talk about creating high-end experience
but still want to make it
super convenient comfortable people to
to hang out
in the name
in in the culture that's being built and
now it seems it extends into the food so
you can never get the question of what
is that we get the question how do you
prepare that people know what it is
they're familiar
this we don't want we want elegant but
we don't want this coming here to feel
like a job right we want it to be easier
and comfortable
so when you were looking at okay i have
to hire a head chef like what were some
of the things you were was that chef one
two three or four
all before we opened pretty much right i
know it's hard um
you do tastings or at least my partners
do tastings i don't
do that
and they're way better food people than
i am
you do taste things you look at your
experience where they work is it
comfortable and
comfortable and
comparable
in terms of volume quality and
the experience that they would have had
to provide for at their other locations
as somebody for example who worked in a
diner and served a thousand people it's
great they could handle volume that's
not our experience if somebody works at
a 20-seat very high-end
that's i'm sure the food is great but
just because you could serve 20 doesn't
mean you could serve 200 at a time so
you kind of look for somebody who's
comparable in quality
and comparable in terms of experience
and then you keep your fingers crossed
yeah and the experience is a big one
in terms of not only just executing the
food but managing a team that executes
the food there's a lot of people i feel
don't necessarily
think of
a kitchen as being this it's an organism
you know you have a lot of different
running pieces especially when you have
a larger restaurant uh if you have event
spaces and you're running a dining room
at the same time there's a lot of moving
pieces and you need to have somebody
who's able to
manage all of that and that's someone
who's just only able to execute a
beautiful dish but able to manage a team
under them as well and make sure that
they're executing on a daily basis and
also
while doing that keeping your costs in
line making sure that you're profitable
while providing these services i mean
there's a lot that goes into being a
chef outside of
you know the glamour of being able to
put together like a beautiful dish that
you see in like a tv show right and then
to make one steak versus a hundred and
be able to have a consistent quality my
wife could cook a spectacular dinner for
four or six and she has frequently she
couldn't be our chef right um
there's so many moving parts in terms of
things going on at once and timing and
the timing gets thrown off with an event
versus the regular diners and the chef
having to pivot and
it's
it's uh it's more of a mash unit than an
assembly line right like they have to
figure it out and not everyone could
handle that there's a lot more people
who can cook a high quality dish than
who can be a chef at a restaurant like
this and is it leadership the skill
that's missing
it's leadership is a good thing when you
have it yeah
that's
they are there's the chef is a captain
down there and people look to him and
when it gets hairy he he is the captain
of a ship yeah and
that's
at least for me not being a
food person particularly it's the
scariest part of the restaurant business
it's the most important part maybe
they're all important
um people could differ for me it's the
one
somebody said what keep what keeps you
up at night it's not the plumbing leaf
at 3 a.m yeah because that i could one
way the other i could deal with it right
getting a kitchen to operate efficiently
and consistently and cost effectively
scares the heck out of me
and how much do you involve the chef in
in
in food costs and budgeting and
like totally right completely in it's
completely he knows what he has to work
with every week every month
he knows what his labor has to be he
knows what his food course has to be
at times often times several times a
year you have to review your pricing
because the cost of the ingredients is
not
it's it moves it's that or change menu
items that's you change menu if you
can't do something profitably you got to
move on if something is not selling you
got to move on yeah it's it's a very
much a moving target that always changes
right and um
and then the environment we're in now it
perhaps changes more frequently than at
times in the past but it's
he's involved in every part of this
so for someone certain restaurant
they're thinking not just how to create
a great meal but how do i create an
experience what are some of the things
that they should think about before
getting started
uh in terms of creating a great
experience i think it goes back to what
is the experience that you want
your guests to have and so if you are
there and you've created a restaurant
around a chef
and it's about their food then that goes
all the way back again to training your
staff making sure they know the ins and
outs of those dishes and make the guests
comfortable with it if you have a type
of restaurant where it's going to be a
little bit adventurous for most of your
guests and people who are going out
because they like
to go out to eat all the time in their
foodies and they like to experience
different types of foods then
the knowledge is really really really
really important for everybody to be
able to
guide these people through these dishes
and make sure that they're going to
enjoy
like i say food is really personal so
even in those types of restaurants where
it's built around a chef and built
around what they're providing you still
want to make sure that the guests are
going to enjoy you want to make sure
that they don't have any sort of
allergies or even food aversions there's
so many different food aversions that
people have and if
a dish can be slightly tweaked just so
that that person can enjoy themselves
and that's really really important
and
it boils down to making sure that
they're going to be comfortable and have
their personal experience is really good
it's the same thing with like a bottle
of wine it's really easy like on on my
side i think i'm on the floor as a
sommelier you can go into all these
floral wording or descriptions about
wine but it's really useless at the end
of the day right if you can't
give somebody what they want i like
asking somebody what's the last thing
you drank that you really loved okay and
you use a lot more general and broad
terms when it comes to something like
that and then
sort of guide them there and then you
can sort of also gauge whether or not
somebody's open to trying something new
and that goes for the food as well right
it's like did they come here to get
their steak and potatoes or do they want
to try
some sort of seafood that they've never
had before right
and so taking that approach down now
into wines it's easy it's easy to feel
intimidated by a wine list absolutely
you have to look it and not know all the
lingo that goes with it yeah now if
you're trying to build high-end but also
comfortable you don't want guests
feeling intimidated by not knowing the
language or not knowing what kind of
wine to buy so how do you then
translate that experience into
recommending wines for people
um well like i'm saying you use a lot
more general terms and i find asking
people what they like to drink on their
own is really important
because you don't want to guide somebody
just towards what you think because most
of the time especially in some way
community what we like to drink is not
necessarily what our guests like to
drink right
so you want to make sure that they're
happy and so i mean the list that we've
built here is full of a lot of really
classic producers that
people will be familiar with but there's
also a lot of stuff that they won't be
and some more esoteric options for our
clientele
that you can find people and see whether
or not they're open to that but you
never want to push somebody into that
you have to be able to read what they
want and gauge what they want based off
what they're telling you but you have to
ask right you have to ask the question
you don't need to be going into really
technical terms and talking about tannin
and acidity and all this other stuff
because that then it gets intimidating
again right you just be like do you like
something that's like
light and fresh you want something
that's like really big bold and start
with general terms and people feel a lot
more comfortable with that right
if they want to go deep you can go
you can deeper
deep if you want to and there's some
people who who will geek out with you
and they get really excited about it
but then there's others who get really
freaked out they're like just just give
me something that i can drink with
myself just flat i'll tell you this is
what i like i come here all the time
yeah and yeah there's people who they're
going to drink the same thing every
single time they come in just what they
drink at home this is what they drink
out and at home it's the only thing they
like to drink right this is my thing
um and that's fine too you just want to
make sure they're happy right
we talked in a previous episode about
the knives that you have the knife
collection vips will have their own
names on their underneath engraved and
you have it in a beautiful case at the
back and you pull it out and they get to
eat with their knife are there any other
like that creates the
culinary experience when i'm kind of
with my knife that's just a normal one i
do any other habits or or things
obviously remember you try to remember
the people and nova does a great job
doing that too but are there any other
things that you've done
as a restaurant on a whole to try to
make people feel welcome and coming back
i mean you make notes of those things
it's not just mental notes from servers
but it's using an entire team to keep
note of things like that if somebody
really enjoyed something
and
they come back you want to have a note
saying like this is what they had last
time that they were here yeah
and they had x y and z on this visit
marked the date and so people get a chit
we call them yeah and you see what this
guest liked where they liked to sit if
they like to sit in a certain area of
the restaurant you try and map that out
so that they get to sit in that section
again if they like a certain server a
lot you see them with that server again
it's being aware of what your guest
preferences are and making sure that so
how do you manage that that sounds like
it's a crazy system to keep track of
everybody's help okay computers
or if i call in and i'll say this is
what i want you to do for these people
yeah anything from
allergy to it's their anniversary have a
cake and a cat like whatever so when
they they're sad their server is given
this and they then know what has to
happen at that table
and it's
it's not as hard or as random as you
think i used to think it wasn't hard
except people kept messing up so maybe
it's hard right but
with enough practice we don't miss as
often as we did but um
and it's like anything else if you don't
turn over your staff that often and our
front of our house staff has a
relatively low turnover
they begin they know everybody so like
they don't have to remember
the regular customers and what they like
they know them vice versa
it's a lot easier right a high turnover
staff that probably
more
that has to be more carefully monitored
right but here it's it's not as
challenging as you would think um
yeah the the the knife thing isn't as
much culinary as it is uh part of the
overall experience like the steak
doesn't taste better because you're
using a knife with your name on it that
just feels like it does not taste better
i don't know it probably oppresses
whatever you're trying to impress that's
for sure yeah um
but yeah it's again it's part of the
what we discussed earlier about an
overall experience from the time you
walk in yeah to the time you shut the
door behind you yeah that that component
yeah uh and make it sound like everybody
it's not it's
it's a select few yeah becoming a little
less selective
but it is people have to earn their
knives in one of a number of ways right
yeah i mean experience makes anything
taste better right of course it's
because you have a great experience yeah
you're going to remember that more than
you are well even the plate section
yeah right it's not a paper plate that's
coming out on correct and like there's
the
less formal like i or a manager walk by
a table and say you know what you're
missing such and such side with what
you're getting you should get i'll just
buy it for them and bring it to them and
when they feel like they have an owner
or manager or guest who they have never
been here before
and they go wow like they watched over
they came they talked to me they gave me
something because they said you know
what you're missing
brussels sprouts that would really go
well and you just tell the way to bring
them some brussels oh my god they come
back for the rest of their life right
and so it's just like
and it's again i don't know do i know
what goes with i just like to talk to
people so i
do stuff
but again it makes everybody feel like
part of a again nothing tastes better
because of it except to the extent
things takes better if you feel like
you're
more important than and people are
paying attention to you right so
and one of the things i think i'm taking
the most from all of our sessions so far
is that you have a very specific
experience you want to create for the
customers and then everything has to be
consistent with that experience from the
moment you
see the sign outside to walk in and meet
people to the environment to the food on
the table like everything has to match
up with that experience and when you do
that
customers can't necessarily even
identify the one thing that made them
feel great they just love the restaurant
and talking about you when you look at
our line we're a very aesthetically
pleasing restaurant with really cool
artwork and like the design is great
but looking like this
doesn't allow you the luxury of not
having everything be first class like
you can't look like this and serve so-so
food it doesn't line up right or have a
waiter who doesn't care right like
once you look like this you create a
standard that you yourself have to um
live up to right putting tablecloths
down right you're saying look at me more
critically i just it is it's making a
more formal experience
um and these are all part of the thought
process when you build your place like
we said earlier on what do you want to
who are your customers what do you want
it to look like smell like feel like
sound like and you have to have this
vision in your head of what it's going
to be who's going to be sitting there
and then go and create create around it
and if you do that you can
you can be successful
um it's not random
it looks random it's our job to make it
feel random it's not it's designed
yes yes so if you had one last piece of
advice you want to give to up-and-coming
restaurant tours around that experience
what do you think uh is the details are
important and the follow-through on
those where like we were talking about
uh
just having notes on returned guests
to noticing small things at a table and
falling through on those and then
following through on the systems that
you built and following up it's always a
lot of follow-through and attention to
detail and
like nelson said you pick the experience
that you want to create
then you set your system up and you
follow through on it and obviously
nothing's perfect nothing's gonna work
exactly the way you want it to the first
time because you build this whole thing
and then you open and you have your soft
opening and you find everything that
doesn't work with your system so you
have to be malleable and be able to
actively fix those things but you have
to be proactive it's non-stop work it's
always i mean it's a living breathing
organism and you have to pay attention
to every little piece that's awesome i
love it
this is episode nine we're talking about
the importance of giving back
why does it matter for a restaurant to
give back
uh okay let's go backwards i'm not sure
it does matter for a restaurant to give
back
i think it matters for people to give
back and if you happen to own a
restaurant it gives you a vehicle to
help do that
and so i'm very conscious of using the
hunt and fish club
and some of our our other spots as well
for that purpose
i would argue it's good for business
but
this is more of a personal passion than
a
need for a restaurant
against dating it's also good for
business right okay
so how do you decide what like what do
you do how do you decide which which
caused the help there's so many good
causes out there what does it look like
and the answer is i would in theory help
every one of them um
i started a informal thing and i call it
an informal thing because it doesn't
actually exist other than i reference it
it's not a corporate
it's called hfc cares hunt and fish club
cares it's not a corporation it's not
anything okay but when we
host events for different organizations
um such as for example daryl strawberry
hosted an uh
event for his charity which deals with
opioid addiction
and he it's a big part of his life
i'll promote it to try to get people
involved with hfc cares as a tag and
then daryl strawberry's opioid edition
or right for the last couple of years we
did some very very major
events here
for
lou gehrig disease als
unfortunately one of our partners
contracted als and is not long ago
passed away
from it but we did some monster events
in this room
i price it in a way that is very very
affordable and
almost makes it impossible for the
organization to not make money
but still being loyal to the restaurant
and just not giving everything away
there is a
an amount and a pricing and a structure
that assures that
selfishly
two things happen one is personally i'm
at a point in my life i feel very good
about when i'm able to do this and i
know everyone says that but i actually
do and it means a lot to me and maybe
we'll talk about some stuff i'm
personally involved with so i do feel
really good when i'm able to do this for
various organizations
so much so that uh an organization i'd
actually never heard of but i kind of
like recently asked me to be on the
board of it it's i won't mention the
name but because i haven't decided yet
but it's a 175 year old organization
this is their 175th year and
so it's not a flyby night yeah um
and so the one is selfishly i feel very
good about it two
people who come to charity events
often are somewhat well-heeled and some
percentage of them didn't know i exist
before the
charity of it so
it is a form of marketing in and of
itself
um that people come and say oh what a
beautiful room oh this was delicious and
so on so perhaps there's residual
benefits right that's the
selfish part of it but really the
selfish part of it is i allow myself to
feel really good about what i'm doing
here
um
in a way that
without this i wouldn't have that option
how would you go about deciding how much
hfc cares you know becomes like how many
nights a month would you give the
discounted rate like how do you balance
between i'm trying to make money and
this
okay so i speak with the organization i
think who's their audience yeah uh one
of the things is
would a slower night here
mean anything for them like would they
do just as well on a
slow night as a busy night do they need
that or can i use a slower knight for it
or could i
price the menu in a way
that still allows us to not
take much of a loss or break even or
something like that
that still satisfies their needs
how can we
size their event by doing the entire
restaurant instead of a room that allows
them more cash flow to come in
i also
use hfc cares to notify our universe of
people whether our partners our regulars
i send emails out like you want to
participate in this this is what we're
doing this is who they are
and often people do um
because people are good they want to
help if they can and uh
so we get a benefit out of it in that
context
like uh an interesting one we did a on
no notice i got a call for the old
yankee catcher jorge pasada okay known
him for a long time
i wanted him to do an event to raise
money for puerto rico
right after their hurricane but the call
was in october and
he and i figured all right and i was
wrong because people still care but i
said all right after new year's
christmas all that no one's gonna care
about it i was wrong people still care
about it but that was what was in my
head yeah like i think news cycles right
yeah um
and i said all right these are the days
we have and i guess
okay this is challenging in october
you're coming into christmas we did it
on a sunday night uh in november uh this
was november of 17.
and
we called in some favors for some
friends some salon he had plenty of old
baseball players and that was easy
but we also called in some music people
we got somebody from hamilton to perform
we got ryan tedder from one republic to
perform who did a duet with bernie
williams the old yankees oh wow okay i
was totally impromptu okay and what was
funny about that is
when bernie came
we
and we've since become very friendly i
just did his birthday party here
he just came as jorge pisano's friend
and i help out then he saw the music and
he goes i wish i had a guitar i
performed i had my manager go find a
place to buy an acoustic guitar on a
sunday night in manhattan not so easy
but he found it he sat downstairs with
ryan tedder for 10 or 15 minutes they
worked out what they were gonna do and
they performed together uh four or five
songs
which was kind of cool actually yeah
and uh i said we had somebody perform
from
hamilton a pretty good name
so it was an amazingly successful at
night
and we raised on relatively no notice i
forgot the exact number if it wasn't 160
000
it was close yeah and no notice or
something we were able to put that
together of course
i didn't need it to be a wednesday night
which otherwise had a
abc brokerage from christmas party
booked right i was able to do it as
against nothing right so we're able to
it was easy to make that work because of
who like the name jorge posada and all
the old yankees right it just sort of
organically people were going to come
anyway even though it's not necessarily
the most convenient time slot giving the
time of the year it would have been in
april maybe it would have worked on a
monday night like right so we were able
to just figure out how to make it work
in a timely way
so
what would a charity
have to do to get your attention like
what are the techniques
okay exist and sort of make sense to me
right so what makes sense what's the
check box so
one thing i'm working on something with
some help uh from some friends yeah
right that's a ringo song right yeah
yeah
um
i saw a 60 minutes episode a few years
ago um called which they titled the
hidden holocaust yeah i'm one of those
nerdy guys who watched 60 minutes right
and
it was about a
priest father patrick and what he did is
he
traveled around the russia poland border
finding
holocaust victims who were never
identified they didn't die in the camps
they were i think his term is holocaust
by bullets they were shot shoved into
the ground covered up and everyone has
seen
pictures of that
well what this episode was about was
that whatever it is 70 75 years later
those people were never addressed they
were just sort of left there
and it just moved me and
emotionally emotionally it moved me in
two ways one it's horrific
that the
last moment on earth of
some woman holding her baby is
some german guy shooting her in the back
and falling into a ditch and having dirt
thrown on her right and then nobody ever
said we know you're here they never came
to say goodbye nothing
emotionally that's where my family is
from and most of my family died in the
holocaust so it occurred to me that
some of those people in the halls in the
ground
were my people
relatives or friends of relatives but
these people are in my universe right so
it's okay so so then fast forward one
day yeah um i'm speaking i get a phone
call from reporter lara logan but so it
hit me emotionally but i i'm lazy i
didn't do anything about it okay and
then one day i got a call from lara
logan who i adore and she's one of the
60 minutes um reporters and she said i'm
coming in tonight are you there like
sure you want to have dinner because you
could join me i'm having dinner with the
priest i'm like there's a punch line
there was
a restaurant owner lara logan and a
priest like i'll keep going so
i come i sit down and we're talking and
talking and
um
it was father patrick it was a lara
logan
episode i hadn't yet been friendly i
became friendly with her sometime after
i saw that episode i remember the
episode i didn't remember who the
reporter was
and it was
har and this was the priest who made it
his life's work
with the permission of the pope to go
and find these bodies and go into old
towns and talk to them
and
recognize them and tell them we found
you when we didn't forget about you and
then this is his life's mission is to
find all these unmarked graves on the
largely on the russia poland border um
and so i said all right
how does it happen that this little
lawyer guy from brooklyn
someday find himself watching a 60
minutes episode and next thing he knows
he's having dinner with the people in
manhattan from that episode this french
priest and lara logan has a lot of
moving parts yeah the odds of this
happening is like the first thing i
thought of is go buy a lottery
this was not meant to happen
then
i'm thinking either
because i'm a little bit religious and
another topic we'd have to go to um
either comma or
intervention it was meant for me to be
in this spot the odds of this happening
are yeah this is kind of a cool
restaurant and we get these types of
people yeah but a french priest who
takes up who finds
victims of the holocaust
and lara like that's kind of remote yeah
and so i said um and lara asked me and i
was inclined she goes do you think you
could help with them i'm like
yeah i think i could okay um
one of the things this restaurant has
given me is the good fortune of a really
good
network of people who come in and out of
here better i mean i always was very
lucky i had lots of friends and
wonderful family and all that
this restaurant gave me a platform where
i have even more perhaps so i undertook
through some friends some pr friends
some well-heeled friends to
help them get their word out like
because the other part of me had said
why have i never heard about this until
i watched 60 minutes right
and
so
i adopted that as something i care about
and there's others that i care about so
right it hit me
a because of
the uniqueness of it
b
because of
this is sort of where my family is from
right
i'd see it i hope i don't stop crying
my father was in world war ii and he was
one of the people who liberated
he was one of the camps no no he wasn't
there as a victim he was there as a user
he was liberating he was liberating
collaborating one of the camps
and um
i in my head i'm thinking he did his
part this is mine nice
so that's why i care about it that's
awesome
so i get to use this place to help sort
of make that happen that's cool
is your dad still around
my dad passed a year and a half ago did
you start your work like did he know you
were doing this no no
no he like many world war ii
um people
and i
when i said there was some other
intervention that's what i was referring
to your dad your dad put those people in
your restaurant yeah it's pretty cool
so
um
i had kind of thought what do i want to
do and he had a great life he died he
was 91 and a half and i say half because
it was his half birthday
and um
there's some other charities that i'm
involved with and i
um i wanted to do something for one of
them and his memory and in honor of my
mom who's old but still with us yeah and
the only thing i tell when you get older
is you get a little more annoying i
always thought at some point you just
softened okay i guess it could go either
way yeah so um what does she think about
this
don't spend too much money okay
uh things oh that's lovely don't give
give him 18 18 is a meaningful number in
the jewish religion so
but at 91 years old she still thinks
that's a lot of money so yeah she thinks
it's all very nice but
um i dedicated but after he died i
thought of a lot of things that i could
do in my dad's memory and honor my mom
and i
that i raised money
just by on pretty much on facebook but
not through facebook just telling people
who i'm friends with yeah i'm raising
money to build another bunk at a camp
for
it's the only kosher camp in america for
very very sick children okay i mean
there's a few for kids with cancer but
this is deformities and like it's rough
stuff okay and the bunks are a lot of
money because they're like [ __ ]
hospitals okay it's not a normal like
you go to a summer camp bunk it's a
piece of wood and a mattress and a cubby
hole yeah this is real stuff
so and where is it it's in upstate new
york and uh the name of it is camp
simcha okay so i wrote i'm doing this i
want to dedicate a bunk in memory of my
father and honor my mother
and i uh
when i was talking to the organization
i've been involved with them for many
years
probably about 25 years maybe more
a friend of mine from college got
involved with it so i started helping
him
and it's 25 years plus later yeah and so
i said how much is it a bunk and he goes
that's uh about 300
000 to 400 depending oh that's not cheap
is that a year in total no no just to
build it just oh i see you have to build
it um
all right he said i'll tell you what he
goes if you could raise 50 000 i could
raise we can dedicate a bunk and honor
your mom and in memory of your dad
nice okay
i said that doesn't sound very
challenging i'm pretty sure i could do
that yeah easily yeah i said so let's
make it a hundred okay
and so i just went on facebook and said
everyone this is what i'm doing i
attached the link okay
we dedicated the bunk last summer
i think i'm somewhere north of 220. wow
that was the whole thing awesome yeah i
got closer than i thought that's great
and more than that a few of the
bigger givers actually have gone up
there fell in love with what they saw as
it's what i like about it is i was a
summer camp
kid i'm also on the foundation of the
charity yeah summer camp which was for
poor but healthy people yeah um i'm a
summer camp person up there
the kids aren't they're just kids like
they're always sick yeah
and um because i asked my friend to
introduce me like how do you do this
every day sick kids is rough he goes you
didn't make them sick you're part of the
solution right and um
so when you go up there you see a whole
bunch of kids they're not sick kids
they're always sick they're kids in
summer camp and they're having fun and
they're very happy and
i thought that moved me to want to get
them
this is
like they're always sick but here every
other kid is sick too right so they're
not special right and um
and it's actually a pretty wild place
and the pla they have every and nobody
the camp is free yeah whether the
sick child is poor or wealthy it's
irrelevant they take
and they're limited how many kids they
could handle at a time it's like a four
to one they need medical staff and
um so that's why building a bunk
it sleeps six kids and six every kid
gets their own counselor these are
really sick kids so each bunk sleeps 12
six get six ounces they have four
sessions so and my head is like
i'm gonna cry i'm sorry
every year
24 very sick kids
will get to go to camp
and they'll see my parents name
and that's why they're there
and it's the best part of their life
and it is the best part of their life
yeah for that window of time any thank
god many of the kids what the kids would
like with
forever ms and stuff they don't get they
are what they are but cancer kids often
get better most do
they come back and their counselors like
they become counselors and they become
donors and they grow up to become
doctors and lawyers and they help so
it's it's not an organization that has
this annuity that i keep funding and
they live off the interest every year
they start at zero
and they do there's other components to
it the camp is the most visible but
in terms of budgeting it's maybe i don't
know 15 of their budget they do a lot of
other really good things but that's the
one you could drive to and show people
yeah and so yeah it's it's not lost on
me yeah obviously
um
well
this
obviously has a huge impact on your life
and the importance
i'm wondering
taking it back now to not just
restaurant entrepreneurs entrepreneurs
just
what do you tell someone who is
i have my restaurant to run i have my
business to run like this takes time i'm
losing money i gotta make rent like i
tell them that
in fact i might record you and play just
like that instead but then what i say
and what i do it's there's a disconnect
so how do people
is it important to find time to
whether it's giving money and raising
money campaign or even just
volunteering time it's important for
everyone to feel like they're helping
the world be better
and there's a million ways that it
happens and i would never pretend
that what i do is the only way or the
best way or anything else right it's
what i'm comfortable with and
everybody should do what they're
comfortable with the restaurant is a
resource to make this happen
it's not done to promote just you know
so is inheriting a trillion dollars like
there's a lot of things that give you
wherewithal to do stuff sometimes it's
money sometimes it's time there's
no shortage of ways to do it
and you just tell everybody whether
you're rich or poor whether you're a
young or old there's a lot of ways
and it's very selfish you feel really
good
like if the yankees lose but then i do
something for charity i forget about the
yankees until tomorrow
so cool well thank you for sharing your
story appreciate it
what's the mindset we need to have to
have success as a restaurateur
jim valvano don't give up don't ever
give up okay this is hard yeah
there are from the day you start to the
day you say goodbye there's going to be
obstacles and hurdles um
there's gonna be a wall in front of you
you don't just stop and stare at the
wall you you run through it you climb
over it you go around it you just gotta
keep going
the
always remember why you did it
and
stay focused on it and it's um
you got to be very very tough it's
there's a lot of employees in this kind
of a restaurant
a lot of personalities a lot of peaks
and valleys
more valleys at times than peaks
but you need a mindset of
you can get through anything
there's nothing crippling except closing
everything else you can kind of figure
it out it's degrees of heart
having said that
i'm certainly not a hero it gets really
hard and
there's a lot of stuff you can control
some stuff you can't
but what you could always control is
your
reaction to it um
you know like we've had days where on
some incredibly busy days the sprinkler
system in the kitchen goes off
and everyone there is drenched and i
have to tell 200 people could he come
back tomorrow
it's
it's gonna happen just matter when and
on what day if you're lucky it's lunch
and there's three people sitting here
yes
and sometimes it's not so but the
mindset is
be loyal to
your own morality why you did this what
you expect out of it and just
keep
challenging yourself to get yourself
back to that center like this is why i'm
here this is what i want the place to
smell like look like touch like feel
like
this has happened to us and i have to
get around it to get back to that center
and it's always get back to the center
and keep going
what's the center for you what does that
look like
a few hundred people sitting here
laughing smiling loving what they do
writing good reviews giving me a hug and
telling me they're gonna come back and
getting a call and saying my kid is
coming in tomorrow with this on a first
date can you make him look really good
in front of the new girlfriend and all
of that and i love that stuff
so
chris dennis i feel like going back to
one of the earliest
discussions i feel like i'm in party
mode
right i want this to be a party and it's
a fun place people don't go out to
restaurants to have a lousy time
they want to like it they want to be
happy they want to feel like they got
their money's worth they want to feel
like they were paid attention to
it's for you to lose like they come in
wanting that so you already have a leg
up
they don't come up here and go show me
maybe a critic does but for the most
part people come here because they've
heard something good they want to have
fun or they just walk by and noticed you
but either way
they wanna they want a good experience
and they want to be happy and they want
to leave smiling our job is
to get them to that whether or not
everything is perfect
you still want them to get to that point
and on nights where we have that and i
hear the vibrancy of
the room
and
people laughing and ordering drinks and
staying longer than they thought i love
that stuff
it's very cool so when you get that 3
a.m wake up because the plumbing system
is broken not so cool right
you know maybe there's days you're
saying why do i why do i keep going why
do i keep doing this
what do you
what do you come back to what do you
tell yourself
it's
i never get to the point of why do i
keep doing this it's
i know i'm doing it it's
how do i get beyond this like what has
to happen right do i have to go in do i
have to get on the phone do i have to
write a bigger check than i planned
to like do i have to apologize to
somebody do i have to yell at somebody
it's it's not so much of why do i keep
going it's what do i have to do to get
it to be okay again
and
there's always an answer right like
there just always is you have to figure
out what
is the answer what's the fastest most
efficient way to get to that answer
um
and we've had some doozies of problems
and
they're hard
but
we're still here which is proof there's
always an answer
and
there's a
there's a you can't look to pass the
buck it's never a blame
like as an owner or a manager it's you
uh everything is on us um
i'm not a big fan of
management or owners who don't
ultimately take responsibility
somebody has to be the person willing to
make the last decision in any business
when i practice law when no matter what
you are everyone gets to start kind of
be a little frivolous until the last
person
you know when
something bad happens and they go well
screw up like yeah that's easy for you
to say right i'm the one who has to live
with the consequence of screw right so
somebody has to be
and i don't mean this to sound arrogant
if it does i'm sorry somebody has to be
the grown-up in the room and be the last
voice
on
anything and everything
and
here
you know that's that's no exception
restaurant any other business
somebody has to be the last voice and is
willing to take ultimate responsibility
and
as long as you have that it doesn't mean
you won't make mistakes if you make
mistake like you can't make a decision
if you're afraid of making a mistake
right so you
make the best decision you trust it's a
good one and you also trust your ability
to say if i'm wrong we'll do something
else but either way we'll eventually get
to where
we need all of this to go like when you
run out of money what do you do when you
when the kitchen implodes what do you do
there's all kind of
whatever it is you think of it we've
dealt with it so is every other
restaurant owner
in your line of work and the law we've
all had this junk we say oh crap what do
we do right you got to figure it out and
if you make the wrong choice life goes
on do something all right it's okay
a wrong choice is significantly better
than no choice and
that's and don't
point fingers take responsibility that's
all there's a lot of entrepreneurs who
are great in a crisis
but then struggle to keep the
consistency high when everything is
smooth so like there's a there's a
crisis great let's handle it but then
now that everything's back to normal how
do you not stay complacent and i know
like your messaging has always been like
good enough is never good enough there's
always there's always so how do you make
sure that you're not just you got your
restaurant and it's a good restaurant
it's great but it's like we're pushing
to be bigger well there's the business
side of it which is we want to be bigger
and whatever
then there's the
hospitality side and i always use
baseball references but what joe
dimaggio reference once
why he runs so hard every place because
there's somebody who never saw him play
before okay every night we're having
somebody who's never eaten here before
if somebody's had 99 really good
experiences and you have one mediocre
you never want that to happen but
chances are they'll come back again it
gets up to two or three maybe not
but if you're old for one you're never
gonna see that person again right right
so i kind of like every night you're
starting at zero like there's a whole
new bunch of people
and you gotta start all over and they
have to have the same experience that
the guy who was here a week ago thursday
and
that's you're always starting over again
so like complete you can't be complacent
somebody's gonna walk in their door for
dinner and they don't want to see your
complaint they don't care that you were
good yesterday or you had a good review
on eater or whatever
who cares about that like they're coming
in sitting down spending money it's like
they want to have fun too yeah and um
if they have a lousy time
they're going to tell them well everyone
here yesterday really liked us like that
doesn't help you right so there's
built-in motivation that every day
you're at zero again there's a new
customer with a new experience and it's
a new day a new night whatever it is
and you gotta perform every day you
gotta if you're on broadway show like
you get to take some days off or you
just give a mediocre performance
like years ago i did some stand-up
comedy way back when i was youthful and
funny i'm neither anymore
and
there's an art to telling a joke and
making it sound like you might have said
it 500 times
the audience doesn't if you're to do
that just hand it they can read it right
you have to sound like you've never said
it before yeah right
every day you're starting over and it's
the first time for them right and you
have to perform as if it's the first
time for them so i don't get the
complacency thing like i just don't get
it
different but that's the one-off
location
you know but that's different than my
own motivation of wanting to be big or
better or whatever because i don't
either grow or you shrink i don't
believe there's all there's no such
thing as par in this like if you're not
trying to get
bigger you're going to get smaller
so i kind of think you have to motivate
yourself that way but that's different
than a customer experience that's a
running a business and trying to become
more successful
do you have any
habits or hobbies or things that you you
know who's reading joe joe dimaggio
biographies or like things that you
would
okay but like things that you find that
maybe you meet like people may not see
well how does judo imagine you have to
deal with the restaurant business it
feels totally disconnected but are there
other but it's not so there are other
like those habits that you do that so
no um i do read a lot
of biographies mostly yeah right i find
people interesting
um one of my favorite expressions i
don't think i heard of it i think i
thought of it
i'm not positive
is exceptionalism is never random
interesting right
whether it's a baseball manager is a
good friend of mine tommy laster or
howard schultz or someone in finance
like
there's a reason these people got to the
tops of their profession yeah and when
you read about him kind of try to see
and like learn it's
it's never an accident right like bill
gates had dinner here the other night
and there was nothing random about bill
gates right right he like him or not
like him that's irrelevant
he's not average
and neither is
i don't know
michael phelps or whoever like pick
anyone you want there's a reason these
people got to the tops of whatever it is
they do and yeah i like reading about
them
so that's is that a hobby i don't know
my kids will tell you that it keeps me
from going to
their stuff but really i try to go to
stuff but um
so yeah there's
i do like that stuff do i find it
motivational i find it interesting i
don't know if i'm self-motivated maybe
there's a reason i choose to read that
kind of stuff
but i
i do find it interesting howard schultz
is one of my personal heroes
i've never met him but but just from his
content and uh onward was an amazing
book
yes it was and he grew up near me and i
still never met at least i don't think
maybe we played basketball once when
we're 12 i don't know but i don't
remember meeting him
and who do you pick is it is it business
people sports stars like what kind of
bio would interest you in the bookstore
yeah all of the above anything anything
usually
maybe somebody who's come to the
restaurant somebody gives me a book
things like that um it's just they find
their way to me somehow i guess people
know i like that so that's what they
right
and how are you reading every night i'm
sorry are you reading every night how
often are you eating uh without
something gross as often as i go to the
bathroom
the um i i'm always in the middle of a
book
for the other parts of my life i do a
fair amount of traveling yeah airplanes
are great for reading yeah they i get a
lot done on airplanes and now i do it on
my phone my wife told me how to read the
book on my phone okay it's not the same
experience but it's a little easier on a
plane right
so yeah i'm always in the middle of
something and then i prioritize who's
next sometimes people jump the list i
just
he comes here a lot and we became
somewhat friendly robert j o'neal okay
you know who he is the
navy seal who killed someone
yeah okay i just
got his book okay um and i gave it out
his holiday presents this year i had him
sign like 50 of them i gave them out to
people
so he jumped ahead of a few other people
in my pecking order right um i was at a
function at my
my son's school and he gave it out to a
couple of his teachers he thought would
like it as a holiday gift
and so one of them started to tell me
about it he started reading it and he
goes oh did you start yet i don't know
what's next he goes and then he shut up
because he didn't want like it's not a
movie it's okay yeah but
so that's how he was here it decided to
that's an interesting character we
became friendly and it's very
interesting guy yeah so
and and you've talked a lot about family
throughout the course of this series
whether it's your parents or your kids
or your wife
how do you how do you balance it and
it's one of the biggest things that
entrepreneurs really badly okay really
really badly
um that is something i struggle with
it's not an easy topic i often wonder if
i'm short changing
them yeah in some ways
and i don't have any really great
answers i try not to
i hope i do it okay but
it's not so easy um
it's getting a little better now that
they're getting a little older because
when i come home late at night yeah
they're probably in bed but at least
they're awake yeah it used to be i came
home they were already sound asleep yeah
so i get up early in the morning even
though i get in at times late at night
so at least i see them before they go to
school i try not to be here on the
weekends to be home but home means i'm
still on my phone all day because this
place is open and running and makes
saturday night right it's uh it's very
hard to tell your kids no telephone at
the dinner table when you're on your
phone right that's
especially my 12 year old who
yells in front of it no matter who else
is there daddy no phone right but
you know i'm making light of it but
that's challenging yeah a lot of people
struggle with it i became a father later
in life so maybe i don't take it for
granted about this is what you need to
do to support yourself yeah it's not an
easy
question it's hard
so well i mean we spent a lot of time
together here 10 episodes uh the people
have been watching over 10 weeks
uh you shared a lot of wisdom and i'm
i'm super appreciative for the time you
spend and all the advice that you shared
uh and and also just how um
humble you've been and willing to be
vulnerable and really open up to try to
give back and i'm super appreciative
if you had to leave one kind of final
message for somebody who was thinking of
getting into the restaurant business
they've watched all this but what would
you want to leave them with
i'm not sure whether i say don't or go
for it
um
dig deep and make sure and if you make
the decision don't go halfway this is an
all or nothing
there's no such thing as a restaurant
that's yeah it's getting by either
you're doing well you're closing
so if you're not going to go all in
don't go in but if you do go in be
prepared to go all in and it's
it's a lifestyle it's not a job
awesome thank you man really appreciate
it thank you
to learn how to build a million dollar
marketing agency check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there hey there i'm mark traeger and i
sit down with evan carmichael in a 10
part series because i was able to build
an over million dollar a year business